Hello everyone and before today's show, I have incredibly exciting news for you about a live show. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be at the South Bank to do something that we have not done before. So you will be the first people to hear it. We are telling the story of what is the ultimate Victorian adventure. The date is 1868, the location is Abyssinia, and the Emperor of Abyssinia has been writing letters to Queen Victoria, who rather rudely has not replied to them. So the Emperor of Abyssinia, annoyed about this, has kidnapped a number of British subjects. In response, Britain sends an expedition to rescue the captives. and it is no exaggeration to say it is massive. On this expedition, 13,000 soldiers, 40,000 animals, including 44 elephants, and the British even put down a railway line to transport everything.
大家好，在今天的节目开始之前，我有一个关于现场演出的重磅好消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将前往南岸，去做一件我们从未做过的事情。所以你们将是第一批听到这个消息的人。我们将讲述一个终极维多利亚时代的冒险故事。时间是1868年，地点是阿比西尼亚，阿比西尼亚皇帝一直在给维多利亚女王写信，而女王却非常粗鲁地没有回复。因此，阿比西尼亚皇帝对此感到恼火，绑架了许多英国臣民。作为回应，英国派遣了一支远征军去营救俘虏，毫不夸张地说，这支队伍规模庞大。在这支远征军中，有13000名士兵，40000头动物，包括44头大象，英国人甚至铺设了一条铁路线来运输所有物资。
It's an incredible story full of jaw-dropping events, ludicrous characters, lots of moustaches, lots of general Victorian shenanigans. and as I say, it is the first time that we have ever done it on The Rest is History. I don't want to blow our trumpet, but I think it's going to be an absolute Restless History classic. So if you want to get a ticket for the ultimate Victorian adventure at the South Bank in London, on Friday the 4th of September, you know where to go. The Rest is History.com. The dragon that are seized and raise his cross. crest and brought back heaps of gold into his nest, unto his foes more terrible than thunder,
这是一个令人难以置信的故事，充满了令人瞠目结舌的事件、荒谬的人物、大量的胡子，以及许多典型的维多利亚时代的恶作剧。正如我所说，这是我们第一次在《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）节目中这样做。我不想自吹自擂，但我认为这绝对会成为《历史的余味》的经典之作。所以，如果你想在9月4日星期五在伦敦南岸获得一张终极维多利亚时代冒险之旅的门票，你知道该去哪里。The Rest is History.com。那条被捕获并举起十字架的龙，冠冕并带回成堆的黄金到他的巢穴，对他的敌人来说比雷声更可怕，
glory of his age, after ages wonder, excelling all those that excelled before. It's feared we shall have none such any more. Effecting all, he sold and undertake, valiant, just, wise, mild, honest, godly, drake. This man, when I was little, I did me. as he was walking up Totnes's long street. He asked me whose I was, I answered him. He asked me if his good friend was within. A fair red orange in his hand he had. He gave it me, wherever I was right glad. Take some kiss me and praise, God bless my boy, which I record with comfort to this day. So that was a poem published in 1628 by a man from Devon, as you can tell from the reading.
他那个时代的荣耀，后世的奇迹，超越了所有曾经卓越的人。恐怕我们再也不会有这样的人了。影响着他所做的一切，勇敢、公正、睿智、温和、诚实、虔诚，德雷克。这个人，当我还是个孩子的时候，我见过他。当时他正走在托特内斯的长街上。他问我是谁家的孩子，我回答了他。他问我他的好朋友是否在里面。他手里拿着一个漂亮的红橙子。他把它给了我，我当时非常高兴。带走一些吻我并赞美，上帝保佑我的孩子，我至今仍怀着安慰的心情记录着。所以这是一首由德文郡的一位男士在1628年发表的诗，正如你从朗读中听出来的那样。
Yeah, you could. But interestingly, the first ever poet in Canada to write in English. So that's a lovely little gift there to our Restist History Club member, Mark Carney, who will surely enjoy that. And to all our Canadian listeners as well. And now you've had some Canadian history. No more complaints for the rest of this year, please. So this bloke's name, the first ever poet in Canada that's a writing English, he was Robert Heyman, and he served between 1618 and 1628 as the governor of a short-lived English colony in Newfoundland.
是的，你可以听出来。但有趣的是，这是加拿大历史上第一位用英语写作的诗人。所以这对我们《历史的余味》俱乐部的成员马克·卡尼来说是一份可爱的小礼物，他一定会喜欢的。也送给我们所有的加拿大听众。现在你们已经了解了一些加拿大历史，请今年剩下的时间里不要再有抱怨了。所以这个家伙的名字，加拿大历史上第一位用英语写作的诗人，他叫罗伯特·海曼，他在1618年到1628年间担任纽芬兰一个短命的英国殖民地的总督。
And his father had been the MP in Totnes, in Devon. And this was how, as a boy, the young Robert Heyman had come to meet Sir Francis Drake. And he had been given this orange by the great man. And of course, the orange and exotic fruit. Red, he just calls it, doesn't he? Yeah, the red orange. It's really interesting. Yeah.
他的父亲曾是德文郡托特内斯的议员。这就是为什么年轻的罗伯特·海曼在小时候能见到弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士的原因。他从这位伟人手中得到了这个橙子。当然，橙子是一种异国水果。他只是称它为红色，不是吗？是的，红橙子。这真的很有趣。是的。
That is a reminder of Francis Drake's exotic travels and his circumnavigation of the globe. And obviously this bloke, Heyman, this is the kind of thing you would remember all your life, because Drake, the preeminent, the paramount English hero of the age, perhaps of the entire century. And it's a tribute to the effect that Drake, had on generations of English men and women. You know, the fact that he's embedded in the national imagination as a hero really without peer. I think it's a very touching poem. I mean, kind of there's a quality of naivety to it, which is very affecting. Which I record with comfort to this day, you know, it's lovely. And tribute to kind of Drake's enduring fame, both at the
这提醒了人们弗朗西斯·德雷克那充满异国情调的旅行和他环游世界的壮举。显然，这个叫海曼的家伙，这是你会终生难忘的事情，因为德雷克是那个时代，甚至可能是整个世纪最杰出、最重要的英国英雄。这是对德雷克在几代英国男女心中所产生影响的致敬。你知道，他作为一名无与伦比的英雄植根于民族想象中，这确实是一个事实。我认为这是一首非常感人的诗。我的意思是，它有一种天真烂漫的特质，非常动人。我至今仍怀着安慰的心情记录着，你知道，这很可爱。这是对德雷克持久名声的致敬，无论是在
time when Heyman is writing it and in his childhood. And that fame is unsurprising because in our previous episode, we followed Drake in his ship, the Golden Hind, around the world. The Golden Hind, only the second ship in history to have performed that circumnavigation. And when Drake returns to England, he is a national hero, not just because he has achieved the greatest feat of navigation in all English history, but also because he has robbed and humiliated the King of Spain. He has forced his way into what the Spaniards call the Maréclosum, the closed sea, namely the Pacific. He's ranged at will along the coastlines of Western America, Spain's great American Empire, and he has plundered so much gold and silver and been given so many
海曼写作的那个时代，还是在他童年时期。这种名声并不令人惊讶，因为在上一集中，我们跟随德雷克乘坐他的“金鹿号”船环游了世界。“金鹿号”是历史上第二艘完成环球航行的船。当德雷克回到英国时，他是一位民族英雄，不仅因为他完成了英国历史上最伟大的航海壮举，还因为他抢劫并羞辱了西班牙国王。他强行闯入了西班牙人所称的“封闭海”，即太平洋。他在西美洲海岸线，也就是西班牙伟大的美洲帝国沿岸随心所欲地航行，掠夺了如此多的金银，并获得了如此多的
clothes that the total sum amounts to more than Elizabeth I's entire annual income, so maybe 400,000 pounds in all. So a huge, huge amount of. money. But to remind people, we ended last time with Drake arriving home in Plymouth in September 1580. And he is very anxious, isn't he? Because if we remember, he is very much persona non grata in the courtyards of Spain. And he does not know how Elizabeth will react to his return. Will he be in the deepest of trouble? Yeah. So Elizabeth is notoriously cautious when it comes to foreign policy. She really hates anything that might threaten war. And the problem for Drake is that during his absence, going around the world, the power of the Spanish king has only grown,
衣物，总额超过了伊丽莎白一世全年的总收入，可能总共40万英镑。所以这是一笔非常、非常巨大的钱。但提醒大家，我们上次结束时，德雷克于1580年9月回到了普利茅斯。他非常焦虑，不是吗？因为如果我们记得的话，他在西班牙宫廷里是非常不受欢迎的人。他不知道伊丽莎白会对他的回归作何反应。他会陷入极大的麻烦吗？是的。所以伊丽莎白在外交政策上以谨慎著称。她非常讨厌任何可能引发战争的事情。德雷克的问题在于，在他环游世界期间，西班牙国王的权力只增不减，
you know, his own incredible feats, notwithstanding. So in January 1580, Philip had become the king of Portugal as well as Spain. So this brings him not just the whole of Iberia, but all of Portugal's empire, which like Spain spans the world. And in the low countries, a rebellion against Philip's rule has been blazing there for over a decade. There too, the fortunes of war seem to be turning in his favour. And this is because he has sent a very formidable new captain, which is, this is a guy who is Philip's own nephew. He's called Alexander Farnese, and he is the Prince of Palmer. And Palmer is a name for listeners to remember because his presence in the low countries with a battle-trained army is going to be a very,
你知道，尽管他自己取得了令人难以置信的壮举。所以1580年1月，菲利普不仅成为了西班牙国王，也成为了葡萄牙国王。这不仅带给他整个伊比利亚半岛，还带给他葡萄牙所有的帝国，这些帝国像西班牙一样遍布全球。在低地国家，一场反对菲利普统治的叛乱已经持续了十多年。在那里，战争的局势似乎也开始向他倾斜。这是因为他派了一位非常强大的新统帅，这个人就是菲利普的亲侄子。他叫亚历山大·法尔内塞，他是帕尔马亲王。帕尔马这个名字值得听众记住，因为他带着一支训练有素的军队出现在低地国家，将成为从这一点开始英国与西班牙关系故事中一个非常、
very, very big factor in the story of England's relations with Spain from this point on. And Palmer has been busy pacifying the revolt in the low countries, city by city. And every time he takes a city, his army of 30,000 men becomes that little bit more experienced. And they are parked there just across the sea from England. And what makes this all the more alarming is that Philip is clearly intent on probing the defenses of Elizabeth's own kingdoms, which includes Ireland as well as England and Wales. And in fact, when Drake returns, an invasion force of Spanish troops is still in the field of Ireland, and Catholic priests, including two Jesuits, are on the loose in England.
非常、非常重要的因素。帕尔马一直忙于平定低地国家的叛乱，一座城市接一座城市地征服。每当他攻下一座城市，他那3万人的军队就变得更加老练。他们就驻扎在那里，就在英国对面的海峡彼岸。更令人担忧的是，菲利普显然意图试探伊丽莎白领土的防御，这包括爱尔兰以及英格兰和威尔士。事实上，当德雷克回来时，一支西班牙入侵部队仍然在爱尔兰的战场上，而天主教神父，包括两名耶稣会士，正在英格兰四处活动。
So this is the kind of the alarms that we talked about in our second episode. These are still current when Drake returns. So it's not surprising that Drake, when he's informed this by his wife and by the mayor of Plymouth, who have rode out to the Golden Hind to talk to him, he must be worried that Elizabeth is going to go for the course of appeasement, that she will hand the treasure back to Spain and effectively sacrifice Drake himself. And also sort of foreign policy realists would advise that that's the sensible course
所以这就是我们在第二集中谈到的那种警报。当德雷克回来时，这些警报仍然有效。所以难怪德雷克在从他的妻子和普利茅斯的市长那里得知这些消息后（他们划船到“金鹿号”上去和他交谈），他一定很担心伊丽莎白会选择绥靖政策，她会把财宝交还给西班牙，并实际上牺牲德雷克本人。而且，外交政策的现实主义者也会建议那是明智的做法，
because you have to accommodate to the greater power. Yes. And among these people who are pressing Elizabeth to get rid of Drake, of course is Phillips' ambassador. to her court, a guy called Bernardino de Mendoza, and he is a very, very menacing foe. He's patrician, he's haughty, he is very zealously Catholic, and he is playing the part of a Soviet ambassador in London in kind of 1957. He is all about the subversion of Elizabeth's regime.
因为你必须适应更强大的力量。是的。在这些敦促伊丽莎白除掉德雷克的人中，当然包括菲利普派驻她宫廷的大使，一个叫贝纳迪诺·德·门多萨的人，他是一个非常、非常危险的敌人。他出身贵族，傲慢自大，是一个狂热的天主教徒，他在1957年左右的伦敦扮演着苏联大使的角色。他所做的一切都是为了颠覆伊丽莎白的政权。
And when he sends a message to Elizabeth saying, I want to come and protest about Drake and Elizabeth says, no, I'm not seeing you. Mendoza sends Elizabeth a very blunt warning. A war is easily begun, but not so soon ended. And this, of course, is playing on, you know, Elizabeth knows this. And so, too, to be fair, does William Cecil, Lord Burley, her number two, effectively her prime minister, because he's a man who very much loves to give the forces of papery a bloody nose.
当他给伊丽莎白发信息说，我想来抗议德雷克，而伊丽莎白说，不，我不会见你。门多萨给伊丽莎白发了一个非常直白的警告。战争容易开始，但不容易结束。当然，这在玩弄，你知道，伊丽莎白知道这一点。公平地说，威廉·塞西尔，伯利勋爵，她的二号人物，实际上是她的首相，他也知道这一点，因为他是一个非常喜欢给教皇势力一点颜色看看的人。
He is the great guardian of Protestant England. But he thinks Drake just isn't worth the hassle. you know, come on, he's not worth it. Let's try and keep our powder dry and not get into a massive bust up with the Spanish over him. But there are lots of people in Elizabeth's council who say, hold on, you know, this bloke is a patriotic hero, he's a Protestant hero, you know, you should back him. Domestic opinion and ideological solidarity are more important than bowing the knee to proud, haughty Spain. And profit. Right. All of these things kind of merge.
他是新教英格兰的伟大守护者。但他认为德雷克不值得这么麻烦。你知道，算了吧，他不值得。让我们尽量保持实力，不要因为他而与西班牙发生大规模冲突。但在伊丽莎白的议会里有很多人说，等等，你知道，这家伙是爱国英雄，他是新教英雄，你知道，你应该支持他。国内舆论和意识形态的团结比向傲慢、自大的西班牙低头更重要。还有利润。对。所有这些事情都融合在一起了。
So let's look at Francis Walsingham, Elizabeth Spy Chief. He is an investor in Drake's expedition. And so obviously, if the treasure is kept, he stands to make an enormous profit. But of course, I mean, he's backed Drake for ideological as well as for financial reasons. Right. And there are two other key members of the Privy Council, both of them, great favourites of Elizabeth, both of them investors in Drake's expedition. one of them we talked about in our previous episode, and this is Sir Christopher Hatton,
那么让我们看看弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆，伊丽莎白的间谍头子。他是德雷克远征队的投资者。所以很明显，如果财宝被保留下来，他将获得巨大的利润。但当然，我的意思是，他支持德雷克不仅是因为意识形态，也是因为经济原因。对。枢密院还有另外两名关键成员，他们都是伊丽莎白的宠臣，也都是德雷克远征队的投资者。其中一位我们在上一集中谈到过，他就是克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士，
and his emblem is a golden hind. So Drake has named his ship the golden hind after that emblem. Now, there is a slight problem with Hatton, namely that Drake had executed Hatton's secretary, Thomas Doughty. Right. Lots of listeners will be curious about this. Yeah. Does Sir Christopher Hatton care more about this bloke who'd been his right-hand man and his secretary, or does he care more about having a ship named?
他的徽章是一只金鹿。所以德雷克以那个徽章命名了他的船“金鹿号”。现在，哈顿有一个小问题，即德雷克处决了哈顿的秘书托马斯·道蒂。对。很多听众会对这个感到好奇。是的。克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士更关心这个曾经是他得力助手和秘书的家伙，还是更关心有一艘以自己名字命名的船，
after himself and loads of money. What do you think? I'm a people person. You know, I'm a loyal person. I think I'd care more about my secretary. Would you? I don't believe you for a minute. Ah, come on.
以及一大笔钱？你觉得呢？我是一个重感情的人。你知道，我是一个忠诚的人。我想我会更关心我的秘书。你会吗？我一分钟也不相信你。啊，算了吧。
Of course, Hatton is, I mean, he's a little, you know, that Doughty's relatives are on the scene and are petitioning him. But when Hatton is told how much money Drake has brought back, he goes, brilliant, let's keep him. This is fantastic. I never liked Doughty anyway. I never liked him. He was a rubbish secretary.
当然，哈顿是，我的意思是，他有点，你知道，道蒂的亲戚们都在现场，并且在向他请愿。但当哈顿被告知德雷克带回了多少钱时，他说，太棒了，留着吧。这太棒了。我本来就不喜欢道蒂。我从来都不喜欢他。他是个糟糕的秘书。
Yeah. And the other person, the other key. player who's a massive favourite of Elizabeth's, who is a big Drake fan, is someone who we haven't mentioned yet in this series. We did mention him in our series on The Young Elizabeth. And this is Robert Dudley, who is the Earl of Leicester. He's kind of Elizabeth's ultimate favorite had been her childhood friend. He's very handsome. He's very haughty. He's very dashing. Elizabeth loves all those kind of characteristics in a man. And Lester had been a very likely candidate to marry Elizabeth in the early years of her reign, according to public opinion.
是的。而另一个人，另一个关键人物，伊丽莎白的宠臣，也是德雷克的忠实粉丝，是我们在这个系列中还没有提到过的人。我们在关于《年轻的伊丽莎白》的系列中提到过他。这就是罗伯特·达德利，莱斯特伯爵。他算是伊丽莎白的终极宠臣，曾是她的童年玩伴。他非常英俊。他非常傲慢。他非常潇洒。伊丽莎白喜欢男人身上的所有这些特质。根据舆论，莱斯特在伊丽莎白统治初期曾是非常有可能与她结婚的人选。
I think in reality, Elizabeth was never going to marry him, but it was widely thought that she wanted to. By this point, there's no prospect of Elizabeth marrying Lester at all, but he remains very much a kind of key player at court. She's very, very fond of him. He's a very domineering figure at court, and like Walsingham, he's a hard-line Protestant. I mean, basically he is a Puritan.
我认为实际上，伊丽莎白永远不会嫁给他，但人们普遍认为她想嫁。到了这个时候，伊丽莎白根本没有嫁给莱斯特的可能，但他仍然是宫廷里的关键人物。她非常、非常喜欢他。他在宫廷里是一个非常有统治力的人物，而且像沃尔辛厄姆一样，他是一个强硬的新教徒。我的意思是，基本上他是一个清教徒。
Right. So I would say the Uber Protestant, the Puritan wing of the Privy Council, they are all in favour of Drake. And that is partly because they've invested in his voyage, but it is also very ideological. And so the result is that the Privy Council is split. And effectively, it is therefore down to Elizabeth.
对。所以我认为枢密院的超级新教徒、清教徒派系，他们都支持德雷克。这部分是因为他们投资了他的航行，但这也是非常意识形态化的。所以结果是枢密院分裂了。因此，这实际上取决于伊丽莎白。
The big question, which way will she jump? And the answer reaches Drake a few weeks after his arrival in Plymouth. And she sends him a letter and says, Fear not for your safety. Bring me some of the loot. And so Drake gets a train of pack horses. and he loads them down with gold and silver that he's plundered from the Spanish, and he heads for London. And when he arrives there, the Queen grants him a six-hour interview, and she is obviously dazzled by the
大问题是，她会选择哪一边？答案在德雷克抵达普利茅斯几周后传到了他那里。她给他写了一封信，说，不要担心你的安全。带一些战利品给我。于是德雷克弄了一队驮马，
treasure that he's brought back from his adventures. But I think she is also very smitten by Drake himself. She loves his stories, the Straits of McGellen, New Albion, the Spice Islands. You know, she loves a valiant chevalier. So she admires, his boldness, his courage, his kind of seed. dog, swagger. He is Lord Flashheart in the Blackadder series. I think he makes her go a little weak at the knees. And so she decides, I think Drake's great. He's brought me lots of treasure. I want to keep it. And I, do you know, I'm going to give Drake a massive reward. Now, obviously, this is tricky. It's a delicate, tight rope to tread. If she's going to reward Drake, she wants to do it in a way that doesn't make it obvious and offend the Spanish too much. But she pulls it off absolutely
他装载了从西班牙人那里掠夺来的金银，然后前往伦敦。当他到达那里时，女王给了他六个小时的接见，她显然被他从冒险中带回的财宝所震撼。但我认为她也被德雷克本人深深吸引了。她喜欢他的故事，麦哲伦海峡、新阿尔比恩、香料群岛。你知道，她喜欢勇敢的骑士。所以她钦佩他的大胆、他的勇气、他那种海狗般的狂妄。他是《黑爵士》系列中的闪电勋爵。我想他让她有点心动了。所以她决定，我认为德雷克很棒。他给我带来了很多财宝。我想留着它。而且，你知道，我要给德雷克一个巨大的奖励。现在，这显然很棘手。这是一根微妙的钢丝。如果她要奖励德雷克，她想以一种不那么明显、不至于太冒犯西班牙人的方式来做。但她做得非常
brilliantly. So what she does, she tells Drake officially, register the treasure that you've taken, and have it sent to the tower. But unofficially, she tells him, look, siphon off 10,000 pounds of this 400,000 pounds. And just to put it, you know, that is more than her entire annual income. So 10,000 pounds is a colossal fortune. I mean, enormous. I mean, super rich level, millions upon millions upon millions. And also, I think this reflects very well on both Drake and Elizabeth. She winks at his quietly taking £14,000 for his men. So they are all going to profit massively as well. Wow. Yeah. And Drake also very quietly donates £100,000 directly to the Queen. And again, all this is being done off the books. It's, you know, behind the scenes.
出色。所以她所做的是，她正式告诉德雷克，登记你拿走的财宝，并把它送到塔楼。但非正式地，她告诉他，看，从这40万英镑中挪出1万英镑。顺便说一句，这比她全年的总收入还要多。所以1万英镑是一笔巨大的财富。我的意思是，非常巨大。我的意思是，超级富豪级别，数百万又数百万。而且，我认为这在德雷克和伊丽莎白身上都反映得很好。她默许他悄悄地为他的手下拿走了1.4万英镑。所以他们所有人也将获得巨大的利润。哇。是的。德雷克也非常安静地直接向女王捐赠了10万英镑。同样，所有这些都是在账外完成的。这是，你知道，在幕后。
Mendoza, you know, I mean, he strongly suspects what's going on, but he doesn't have proof. And Elizabeth handles him with a very, very cool display. of duplicity. He is demanding all this time. I want to see you. I want to complain about this. And she retorts to him, well, I will not see you until you have given me a full account of this Spanish invasion that you have launched of my kingdom in Ireland. And it helps that by this point, so we're in November, the rebellion in Ireland has been crushed. So the Spanish task force has been wiped out at a place called Smirwick. So that is now dead and buried. So Elizabeth's hand is slightly stronger. And Mendoza, of course, is not going to apologize for it. So there is a standoff
门多萨，你知道，我的意思是，他强烈怀疑发生了什么，但他没有证据。伊丽莎白以一种非常、非常冷静的虚伪姿态处理了他。他一直要求，我想见你。我想抗议这件事。她反驳他说，好吧，在你给我一份关于你在爱尔兰发动的西班牙入侵的完整说明之前，我不会见你。这很有帮助，因为到这个时候，我们是在11月，爱尔兰的叛乱已经被镇压了。所以西班牙特遣部队在一个叫斯米尔威克的地方被消灭了。所以那件事现在已经死了，被埋葬了。所以伊丽莎白的筹码稍微强了一些。而门多萨当然不会为此道歉。所以陷入了僵局，
and that absolutely suits Elizabeth. She does license the return of 30,000 pounds to Spanish merchants who can prove legitimate claims against Drake, which of course they have to come to London to do. So there are lots who don't do that. But otherwise, she just says, I've investigated this and I have discovered that Drake has no charge to answer. In particular, the accusation that he captured a treasure ship is absolutely rubbish. And I am shocked, shocked that the Spanish ambassador should be propagating such lies. So this is very much your Cold War parallel. Yes. This is like a Soviet and American ambassador saying, well, actually, you are the people who are meddling and going on interventionist adventures. And I'm actually really horrified
这完全符合伊丽莎白的意图。她确实批准将3万英镑退还给那些能证明对德雷克有合法索赔要求的西班牙商人，当然他们必须亲自来伦敦才能这样做。所以有很多商人没有这样做。但除此之外，她只是说，我已经调查了这件事，我发现德雷克没有任何指控需要回答。特别是，他俘获了一艘宝船的指控完全是胡说八道。我感到震惊，震惊于西班牙大使竟然在散布这样的谎言。所以这非常像你们的冷战平行线。是的。这就像苏联和美国大使说，好吧，实际上，你们才是那些干涉和进行干预主义冒险的人。而我实际上真的很震惊，
that you would make these allegations about us when we are so clearly devoted to, you know, peace and freedom and whatever. Yeah. And in fact, they're both like busily intervening each other's affairs and in their client states and all that. Absolutely. And I think Elizabeth can get away with this because Pacific is so far away. It is so fantastically distant. There isn't really any evidence.
你们竟然会对我们做出这些指控，而我们显然是致力于，你知道，和平与自由之类的。是的。事实上，他们都在忙于干涉对方的事务，以及在他们的附庸国等等。绝对是这样。而且我认为伊丽莎白能逃脱惩罚，因为太平洋太遥远了。它太遥远了，简直不可思议。并没有什么真正的证据。
And the truth is she was never going to return such a windfall because she is too mean, too short of money. You know, she's not going to look a gift horse in the mouth. So remember, you said the 400,000 was bigger than her entire annual income, right? Yeah. I mean, this is a point at which the great issue for the monarchy in the 16th and 17th century is raising money. So for her, a windfall like this, it would be suicidal. It would be insane to give that away. You're always going to keep it. Also, she knows from Drake, because Drake has found out this for himself, that one of the reasons why the Spanish forces under Palmer in the low countries are starting to do better is because technological advances in South America are fueling increased silver attraction. from the great minds there. Yeah. So there is an increased flow of silver,
事实是，她永远不会归还这样的横财，因为她太吝啬了，太缺钱了。你知道，她不会拒绝送上门的礼物。所以记住，你说40万比她全年的总收入还要多，对吧？是的。我的意思是，这是16世纪和17世纪君主制面临的最大问题是筹集资金。所以对她来说，这样的横财，放弃它简直是自杀。那太疯狂了。你总是会留着它。而且，她从德雷克那里知道，因为德雷克自己发现了这一点，帕尔马领导下的低地国家的西班牙军队开始表现得更好，原因之一是南美洲的技术进步正在推动白银产量的增加。来自那里的大矿山。是的。所以白银的流动增加了，
which is being fed back to Spain and ultimately to Philip's war against Protestantism. And this war against Protestantism is actively raging in the low countries, but it is also funding the Cold War against Protestant England. And so I think Elizabeth feels, well, if Philip is benefiting from all this silver in his Cold War against me, why shouldn't I use his silver against him? And actually, not just the Cold War, she ships some of the silver to the Dutch rebels in the low countries.
这些白银被输送回西班牙，并最终用于菲利普反对新教的战争。这场反对新教的战争在低地国家激烈进行，但它也为反对新教英格兰的冷战提供了资金。所以我认为伊丽莎白觉得，好吧，如果菲利普在反对我的冷战中从所有这些白银中受益，我为什么不能用他的白银来对付他呢？事实上，不仅是冷战，她还把一些白银运给了低地国家的荷兰叛军。
You know, this sense of proxy battles being fought. Again, that's kind of very American Soviet in the Cold War, isn't it? Yeah, completely. This is a big moment because cautiously, you know, in her kind of classic crabbed and evasive manner, Elizabeth has taken the side of the most hawkish elements in her Privy Council. So Lester and Walsingham and Hatton and so on. And she is actually not afraid to signal this publicly by deploying her incredible genius for theatre, for giving her subjects, scenes that will then glow in their collective hearts. So on the 1st of April, 1581, Elizabeth meets Drake on board the golden hind, which has docked in Deptford down the 10th.
你知道，这种代理人战争的感觉。同样，这在冷战中非常像美国和苏联，不是吗？是的，完全是。这是一个重要的时刻，因为谨慎地，你知道，以她那种典型的刻薄和回避的方式，伊丽莎白站在了她枢密院中最强硬的派系一边。所以莱斯特、沃尔辛厄姆、哈顿等等。而且她实际上并不害怕通过部署她那令人难以置信的戏剧天赋来公开表明这一点，为她的臣民提供那些将在他们集体心中闪耀的场景。所以1581年4月1日，伊丽莎白在“金鹿号”上会见了德雷克，该船已停靠在泰晤士河下游的德特福德，
from London, and there she has him knighted. And it's hard to overemphasise what an insane honour this is for a yeoman son. Elizabeth is very stingy but handing out knighthood. So, for instance, Walsingham, who is her chief secretary, her spy chief, he'd only been knighted in 1577 after years of service. And he is from the kind of background that would entitle him to a knighthood. Drake is absolutely not. He's the grandson of a yeoman farmer. And it is a brilliant occasion. And it seems like the whole of London has turned out for it. Drake is now the great public hero of the English crowds. And the spectators who've gathered in Deptford, they get so excited that loads of them try to pile over the gangplank onto the ship. And the gangplank gives way and they all drop into the mud. And there's great fun, great excitement had by all. And on board the golden hind, Elizabeth very coyly but ostentatiously, loses a garter. And the whole proceeding is a massive propagation to the Spanish. I maintained, by the way, that this would make an excellent carry-on film. I think it would make, Kate Blanchard, I think, missed a trick by not losing her garter on
从伦敦出发，在那里她封他为爵士。很难夸大这对一个自耕农的儿子来说是多么疯狂的荣誉。伊丽莎白在授予爵位方面非常吝啬。所以，例如，沃尔辛厄姆，她的首席秘书，她的间谍头子，他在经过多年的服务后，直到1577年才被封为爵士。而且他出身于那种有资格获得爵位背景的家庭。德雷克绝对不是。他是自耕农的孙子。这是一个辉煌的时刻。看起来整个伦敦都出动了。德雷克现在是英国民众心目中的伟大民族英雄。聚集在德特福德的观众太兴奋了，以至于他们中的许多人试图挤过跳板上船。跳板断了，他们全都掉进了泥里。大家玩得很开心，非常兴奋。在“金鹿号”上，伊丽莎白非常羞涩但又显眼地掉了一只吊袜带。整个过程是对西班牙的一次大规模宣传。顺便说一句，我坚持认为这会是一部出色的《随身携带》系列电影。我认为它会，凯特·布兰切特，我想，错失了一个机会，没有在
the golden hide. That's the shame. I think it would also make a tremendous patriotic, stirring epic. Anyway, so the question is, why has the inveterately cautious Elizabeth taken in such a bold and flamboyant step. We've said she is clearly very impressed with Drake. She thinks he's tremendous. She's always inviting him in for chats. But I think she is also playing four-dimensional chess. And she is very good at playing four-dimensional chess.
“金鹿号”上掉下她的吊袜带。那真是遗憾。我认为它也会成为一部巨大的爱国、激动人心的史诗。总之，问题是，为什么一贯谨慎的伊丽莎白采取了如此大胆和华丽的步骤。我们说过她显然对德雷克印象深刻。她认为他很了不起。她总是邀请他进来聊天。但我认为她也在下四维象棋。而且她非常擅长下四维象棋。
And her move works on a couple of levels. So first of all, it obviously plays well with her subjects. Drake is the great national hero. And Elizabeth knows that by having him knighted, it guilds her own brand. And this is really important because she has to worry that war is threatening. England does remain riven by sectarian divisions. And its future as a Protestant kingdom hangs by the single thread that is Elizabeth's own life.
她的举动在几个层面上奏效了。首先，它显然在她的臣民中很受欢迎。德雷克是伟大的民族英雄。伊丽莎白知道，通过封他为爵士，她为自己的品牌镀了金。这非常重要，因为她必须担心战争的威胁。英格兰仍然被宗派分裂所撕裂。它作为一个新教王国的未来悬在伊丽莎白自己生命这一根细线上。
And so, you know, she's always getting intelligence briefings from Walsingham saying that there are assassins out there. So she wants to she wants to woo her subjects. You know, she wants to make herself the great beloved of the English people. And so therefore it is desperately important to her to project a sense of her rule as something glamorous and golden and self-confident to kind of portray herself as Gloriana. And to that end, having Drake knighted works superbly because to this day, I think, the image of Elizabeth personally dubbing Drake a knight on the deck of the golden hind remains one of the great iconic scenes. of English history. Overseas listeners won't get this, but when we were growing up
所以，你知道，她总是从沃尔辛厄姆那里得到情报简报，说外面有刺客。所以她想，她想讨好她的臣民。你知道，她想让自己成为英国人民心目中伟大的爱人。因此，向她展示她的统治是一种迷人、黄金和自信的东西，将自己描绘成“荣耀女王”对她来说至关重要。为此，封德雷克为爵士效果极佳，因为直到今天，我认为，伊丽莎白在“金鹿号”甲板上亲自授予德雷克爵位的形象仍然是英国历史上最伟大的标志性场景之一。海外听众可能不明白这一点，但当我们成长时
in the 70s and 80s, there were these books called Lady Bird Books that everybody in England read. They were the guides to history. And this is your classic Lady Bird book illustration, isn't it?
在70年代和80年代，有这些叫“瓢虫书”的书，英国每个人都读过。它们是历史指南。这就是你们经典的“瓢虫书”插图，不是吗？
Yes. People cheering with great ruffs, hazzars from the crowd. They didn't have the people falling in the mud. No. Good Queen Bess, who looks gorgeous,
是的。人们戴着大褶皱领欢呼，人群中发出欢呼声。他们没有人们掉进泥里的场景。没有。好女王贝丝，看起来很华丽，
knighting, a very handsome swashbucklings of Francis Drake. Makes you proud to be English. And unfortunately, it didn't actually happen. Elizabeth didn't dub Drake herself.
封爵，一位非常英俊、潇洒的弗朗西斯·德雷克。让你为身为英国人感到自豪。不幸的是，这并没有真正发生。伊丽莎白没有亲自授予德雷克爵位。
but she got a Frenchman. Oh my God. This is literally the worst moment in the history of the podcast. A guy called Monsieur de Marchemort to do it. But obviously, Elizabeth wouldn't have asked Marseumour to Knight Drake had she not been confident that Marcia Moore would do it. And it was also Marcia Moore who picks up Elizabeth's fallen garter, which she'd coyly let slip. And it's all very flirty.
但她找了一个法国人。天哪。这简直是播客历史上最糟糕的时刻。一个叫马尔什莫先生的人来做这件事。但显然，如果伊丽莎白不确信马尔什莫会这样做，她就不会要求他封德雷克为爵士。而且也是马尔什莫捡起了伊丽莎白掉落的吊袜带，她羞涩地让它滑落。这一切都非常调情。
So it's a proper Entente Cordial between England and France. And so here I think is another reason for all these tremendous theatrics aboard the golden hind. Elizabeth is sending a public message to Spain about the strength of her relationship with France. And listeners who heard our second episode, which was all about the St. Bartholomew's Day massacre, may find this odd. Why is a Protestant queen flirting with the ambassador of a Catholic country in which only a decade before thousands of Protestants had been massacred in pogroms across the country and most particularly in the capital in France. And it's a very good question. And to answer it, we just need to do a quick retrospective to look at what has been happening in France since that terrible day on St. Bartholomew's Day in August 1572. Because France, like Spain, is always a preponderant influence on English foreign policy.
所以这是英法之间真正的“友好协定”。所以我认为在“金鹿号”上进行所有这些巨大的戏剧表演还有另一个原因。伊丽莎白正在向西班牙发出一个关于她与法国关系强度的公开信息。听过我们第二集（关于圣巴托罗缪大屠杀）的听众可能会觉得这很奇怪。为什么一位新教女王要与一个天主教国家的大使调情，而在仅仅十年前，成千上万的新教徒在全国各地，特别是在法国首都，被屠杀在大屠杀中。这是一个非常好的问题。为了回答它，我们只需要做一个快速的回顾，看看自1572年8月圣巴托罗缪大屠杀那个可怕的日子以来，法国发生了什么。因为法国，像西班牙一样，总是对英国外交政策有着压倒性的影响。
What happens across the channel in France, the great European superpower, alongside Spain, matters enormously. And basically, nothing good has been happening because the massacre had resulted only in further bloodshed, only in further war. All right. So let's have a look at the situation in France. So basically, we have three rival factions, and each of them, annoyingly, is led by somebody called Henri Henry. You say it's annoying. I think it's quite fun. So they're called Les Traz-Henri in France, the Three Henrys.
在海峡对岸的法国，作为与西班牙并列的欧洲超级大国，所发生的事情非常重要。基本上，没有什么好事发生，因为大屠杀只导致了更多的流血，更多的战争。好吧。让我们看看法国的情况。基本上，我们有三个敌对派系，令人恼火的是，他们每个人都由一个叫亨利的人领导。你说这很烦人。我觉得这很有趣。所以他们在法国被称为“三个亨利”。
And I think that rather getting stressed about the fact that they're all called Henry, I think we should lean into it. Okay. Well, you're easily pleased, Tom. I mean, what's all I say? There was a film made in France in the 70s called The Three Henrys. You know, we always say this about Tudor politics, but there was a kind of Game of Thrones element to it.
我认为与其因为他们都叫亨利而感到压力，不如我们应该接受它。好吧。你很容易满足，汤姆。我的意思是，我能说什么？70年代在法国拍了一部电影叫《三个亨利》。你知道，我们总是这样说都铎王朝的政治，但它有一种《权力的游戏》的元素。
I think it would actually make a really good drama. Okay. So there are these three factions. They're each led by a guy called Henri or Henry. The first of these is the Huguenots, who are bloodied and diminished in the wake of the various pogroms and massacres that happened on St. Bartholomew's Day in 1572. But they haven't gone away. So they've lost Paris. They've lost the north. But they remain strong in the south. And their leader is Henry, Henri, the king of Navarre. And he was the guy whose marriage six days before. the massacre had drawn all the various Protestant nobles to Paris, where they could then be massacred. And Henry himself, the King of Navarre, had been effectively taken, prisoner, kept under house arrest, and obliged to renounce his Protestantism. But then in 1576, he'd been able to escape the court and had immediately resumed his loyalty to Protestantism. And he's very, very impressive, he's very smart, he's very personable, he's military able,
我认为它实际上会成为一部非常好的戏剧。好吧。所以有这三个派系。他们每个人都由一个叫亨利的人领导。第一个是胡格诺派，他们在1572年圣巴托罗缪大屠杀后的各种大屠杀中被血洗和削弱。但他们并没有消失。所以他们失去了巴黎。他们失去了北方。但他们在南方仍然很强大。他们的领袖是纳瓦拉国王亨利。他就是那个在屠杀前六天结婚的人，他的婚礼将各种新教贵族吸引到巴黎，在那里他们随后被屠杀。亨利本人，纳瓦拉国王，实际上被俘虏，被软禁，并被迫放弃了他的新教信仰。但随后在1576年，他得以逃离宫廷，并立即恢复了他对新教的忠诚。他非常、非常令人印象深刻，他非常聪明，他非常讨人喜欢，他在军事上很有能力，
and spoiler alert, in the long run, he is. going to triumph and emerge as Henry the fourth, the most popular king in all of French history, the only king who the French revolutionaries do not kind of chuck out during the revolution. I mean, who would play him? Pedro Pascal, perhaps. Oh, my God. So that's faction number one. Pedro Pascal is leading them. He's the king of Navarre. Brilliant. That's the Huguenots. Faction number two, we're going to go to the other end of the spectrum, aren't we? We're going to go to the absolute kind of ultra-Catholics, right? Yes.
而且剧透预警，从长远来看，他将取得胜利并成为亨利四世，法国历史上最受欢迎的国王，也是法国革命者在革命期间没有推翻的唯一一位国王。我的意思是，谁会扮演他？佩德罗·帕斯卡，也许吧。天哪。所以这是第一派系。佩德罗·帕斯卡领导他们。他是纳瓦拉国王。太棒了。这就是胡格诺派。第二派系，我们要去光谱的另一端，不是吗？我们要去绝对的极端天主教徒，对吧？是的。
So this is the Catholic League, which had been founded by the Duke of Geese, who is the Second Henry, who we talked a lot about in our first two episodes. So he's the absolute darling of the Catholic diehards and the mob in Paris especially. Yeah. He has this tremendous aura of martial glamour, which has been massively enhanced by the fact that he, like his dad, has been given a scar across his face, the result. of a sabre wound that he'd suffered in battle in 1575. And he is by now effectively the ruler of France. He commands the largest armies. He is the effective master of Paris. And he is, he's put the
所以这就是天主教联盟，由吉斯公爵创立，他是我们在前两集中谈论很多的第二个亨利。所以他是天主教死硬派和巴黎暴徒的绝对宠儿。是的。他有一种巨大的军事魅力，这种魅力因为他像他父亲一样，脸上有一道伤疤而得到了极大的增强，这是他在1575年战斗中受到的军刀伤的结果。他现在实际上是法国的统治者。他指挥着最大的军队。他是巴黎的实际主人。而且他，他把
monarchy itself in his shade. And he is ambitious, basically not only to bring France under his control and perhaps his enemies say directly under his rule. You know, there are all kinds of rumors that he wants to make himself king and seize the throne. But he also aspires. to seize the thrones of England and Scotland. And the reason why he can realistically dream of this is because he is the cousin of Mary Queen of Scots. And so if he can depose Elizabeth and marry Mary, he will absolutely be quids in.
君主制本身置于他的阴影之下。他雄心勃勃，基本上不仅想把法国置于他的控制之下，也许他的敌人说直接置于他的统治之下。你知道，有各种各样的传言说他想让自己成为国王并夺取王位。但他还渴望夺取英格兰和苏格兰的王位。他之所以能现实地梦想这一点，是因为他是苏格兰玛丽女王的表弟。所以如果他能废黜伊丽莎白并娶玛丽，他绝对会赚翻。
He'd get both. So who's playing him? Mads-Mickleson, perhaps? Because you're just thinking Scar, are you? I'm thinking Scar. I'm thinking Gaunt, kind of faintly Machiavellian, but impressive. Okay.
他会两者兼得。所以谁来扮演他？麦斯·米科尔森，也许吧？因为你只是在想伤疤，对吧？我在想伤疤。我在想那种阴沉、有点马基雅维利主义，但令人印象深刻的人。好吧。
I mean, he's a smart, you know. The sheaf from Casino Royal. Brilliant. Yes. Do you think, I mean, I think he'd be quite good. Yeah, fine. I mean, you're the casting director. And so our third, Henry, is the actual king of France.
我的意思是，他很聪明，你知道。《皇家赌场》里的那个家伙。太棒了。是的。你觉得，我的意思是，我觉得他会很不错。是的，好吧。我的意思是，你是选角导演。所以我们的第三个亨利，是法国真正的国王。
Yes. Who is attempting somehow to unite his kingdom torn apart by these two factions. And he's Henry III. Yeah. Enrique, Tro. And he is the younger brother of the bloke who was king in the massacre, who was Charles. And he's a dashing. Unusually for a French king.
是的。他正试图以某种方式团结他那被这两个派系撕裂的王国。他是亨利三世。是的。他是大屠杀时国王的弟弟，也就是查理。他很潇洒。对于法国国王来说很不寻常。
We've done a lot of French kings on this podcast who've turned out to be useless and spineless and physically weird in one way or another. This bloke is actually fine. Well, he'd been very dashing as a young prince and he'd won various victories over the Huguenots. And then he had a kind of mad spell as the king of Poland. Never made that choice. And then he'd succeeded his brother and so he'd had to dash back to take over the throne. And he is dashing, but he was.
我们在这个播客中做过很多法国国王，结果证明他们要么没用，要么没骨气，要么在某种程度上身体怪异。这家伙实际上很好。好吧，他年轻时作为王子非常潇洒，他在胡格诺派身上赢得了各种胜利。然后他作为波兰国王有一段疯狂的时期。从来没做过那个选择。然后他继承了他哥哥的王位，所以他不得不赶回来接管王位。他很潇洒，但他
also has suspiciously flamboyant tastes. So a bit like Edward II in England, he's a great one for a favourite, a mignor. And so this generates all kinds of dark rumours of sodomy and cross-dressing and various other things that Catholic kings are not supposed to get up to. And whether these rumours are true or not, he doesn't have any children. And so this is another reason why the Duke of Gies, you know, it seems plausible that he might be suspicious. expecting to replace Henry III and his dynasty. Oh, right. Who's playing him, by the way?
也有令人怀疑的华丽品味。所以有点像英国的爱德华二世，他非常喜欢宠臣。所以这产生了各种关于鸡奸、异装癖和天主教国王不应该做的其他各种事情的黑暗传言。无论这些传言是否属实，他都没有孩子。所以这是吉斯公爵（你知道，这看起来很合理）可能怀疑他会取代亨利三世及其王朝的另一个原因。哦，对了。顺便问一下，谁来扮演他？
Andrew Scott. Superb. Yeah. Okay. So this is a great film. Yeah, it would be. They should make it. So if Mads-Mickleson is going to replace Andrew Scott on the throne of France,
安德鲁·斯科特。太棒了。是的。好吧，这是一部很棒的电影。是的，会是的。他们应该拍出来。所以如果麦斯·米科尔森要取代安德鲁·斯科特登上法国王位，
he needs to get rid of the Valois dynasty, the ruling dynasty. But the Valois dynasty isn't completely doomed. So the French king may not have a son, but he does have a younger brother. And this is a guy called Francois, Francis, and he is the Duke of Anjou, and he is the fourth of four brothers, and the only one who hadn't been a king, which he massively resents for understandable reasons. He's physically quite unprepossessing. He got smallpox when he was eight, and it left him with a pitted face and bandy legs and a twisted spine. But he's a tremendous, he's a very smart, active, calculating guy and very personable. He's a devout Catholic, but not aggressively so.
他需要除掉瓦卢瓦王朝，即统治王朝。但瓦卢瓦王朝并没有完全注定失败。所以法国国王可能没有儿子，但他确实有一个弟弟。这是一个叫弗朗索瓦的人，他是安茹公爵，他是四个兄弟中的第四个，也是唯一一个没有当过国王的人，他对此非常愤恨，原因是可以理解的。他身体上相当不讨人喜欢。他八岁时得了天花，这让他留下了坑坑洼洼的脸、罗圈腿和扭曲的脊椎。但他是一个了不起的，他是一个非常聪明、活跃、精于算计的人，而且非常讨人喜欢。他是一个虔诚的天主教徒，但并不激进。
So he'd been perfectly happy to ally himself with Henry of Navarre, Pedro Pascar, the Huguenot leader. And he's kind of the standard bearer for a new trend in politics, not just in France, but across Europe, which is to prioritize political stability over confessional allegiance. over kind of religious identities. And so to his admirers, he is a pragmatist. He is a man whom the Protestants can do business with. But to his detractors, among whom you would include the Duke of Gies and the Catholic League, he's a trimmer.
所以他非常乐意与纳瓦拉的亨利（佩德罗·帕斯卡，胡格诺派领袖）结盟。他算是政治新趋势的旗手，不仅在法国，而且在整个欧洲，那就是优先考虑政治稳定而不是宗派忠诚。而不是那种宗教认同。所以对于他的崇拜者来说，他是一个实用主义者。他是一个新教徒可以与之做生意的人。但对于他的批评者（其中包括吉斯公爵和天主教联盟）来说，他是一个投机分子。
And the word that hostile Catholics give to him, he is a politic. He is someone who places politics over loyalty to God. Right. But it's this quality. you know, his quality as a politic that in 1578 had opened the door to the Duke of Anjou who at this point is 23
敌对的天主教徒给他的词是，他是一个“政治家”。他是一个将政治置于对上帝忠诚之上的人。对。但正是这种特质，你知道，他作为政治家的特质，在1578年为安茹公爵打开了大门，当时他23岁。
had given him the opportunity to court a woman who is 22 years, his elder. And this is none other than our own beloved queen Elizabeth I first, good queen Bess. Wow.
给了他一个机会去追求一位比他年长22岁的女性。而这位女性不是别人，正是我们敬爱的伊丽莎白一世女王，好女王贝丝。哇。
I was going to say he's clearly going to be played by Manuel Macron, But we should draw a veil over that. So Elizabeth I mean, this issue of who she's going to marry has hung over her ever since she became queen. Yeah, and it's still current. It's still rumbling on. And she has had a number of suits,
我本来想说他显然会由曼努埃尔·马克龙来扮演，但我们还是对此避而不谈吧。那么伊丽莎白，关于她要嫁给谁的问题，自从她成为女王以来就一直困扰着她。是的，而且这仍然是当前的热门话题。它还在持续发酵。她已经有了不少追求者，
including the current king of France. So Anjou's elder brother. But this guy, Francis of Anjou, he'd actually come to England in person to try to woo her. And that's a very big step. He's the only one who's done it, to be fair. But it didn't work. Although Elizabeth quite liked him.
包括现任法国国王。也就是安茹公爵的哥哥。但这个人，安茹公爵弗朗索瓦，他实际上亲自来到英国试图向她求婚。这可是非常大的一步。公平地说，他是唯一一个这么做的人。但没成功。尽管伊丽莎白其实挺喜欢他的。
Well, she thinks she really likes him. I think she's genuinely fond of him. She calls him her frog, whether that's because he looks like a frog or whether it's because the word frog is the English already starting to use that as a term for the French at this point is unclear. And the reason that Monsieur de Mushanour, the guy who picked up Elizabeth Garter and Knight of Drake was in London, was because he was there kind of acting. as Anjou's kind of agent, his kind of marriage broker.
嗯，她认为她真的很喜欢他。我想她是真心喜欢他的。她称他为她的“青蛙”，至于这是因为他长得像青蛙，还是因为“青蛙”这个词在当时已经是英国人开始用来指代法国人的称呼，尚不清楚。而那位捡起伊丽莎白袜带并封德雷克为爵士的穆沙努先生之所以在伦敦，是因为他当时在充当安茹的代理人，也就是他的婚姻经纪人。
Now, the problem for Elizabeth is that the reaction among her Protestant subjects to the notion, the prospect, that she might marry a French Catholic prince is one of absolute horror. So much so that in 1579, when Anjou had been in London in person and had been out for a romantic barge trip on the Thames with Elizabeth, it's likely that a boatman committed an assassination attempt on Anjou. The thing was so embarrassing that it was all covered up, but it almost certainly was an attempt to have Enjou killed. And also in 1579, a lawyer by the name of John Stubbs, a Puritan, had written a pamphlet which compared Enjou to a serpent and Elizabeth to Eve. Okay. Except, you know, there's an issue with comparing Elizabeth to Eve.
现在，对伊丽莎白来说，问题在于她的新教臣民对她可能嫁给一位法国天主教亲王这一想法和前景感到绝对的恐惧。以至于在1579年，当安茹亲自来到伦敦，并与伊丽莎白在泰晤士河上进行了一次浪漫的驳船之旅后，很可能有一名船夫对安茹实施了暗杀企图。这件事太尴尬了，所以被掩盖了起来，但几乎可以肯定这是一次针对安茹的谋杀企图。同样在1579年，一位名叫约翰·斯塔布斯的律师，一名清教徒，写了一本小册子，将安茹比作蛇，将伊丽莎白比作夏娃。好吧。只是，你知道，把伊丽莎白比作夏娃是有问题的。
And so Stubbs had promptly added, she is also our added. and sovereign lord or lordly lady of this land. So for kind of the wrestling with the fact that Elizabeth is a woman rather than a man. But he'd gone all in against enjou as a potential husband for Elizabeth, said that Elizabeth was risking a second St. Bartholomew's Day massacre in London. So that's very punchy. And so unsurprisingly, Elizabeth was furious. And Stubbs ends up having his right hand chopped off for inciting sedition.
于是斯塔布斯很快补充道，她也是我们这片土地的君主和领主。所以，这算是对伊丽莎白是女性而非男性的事实的一种纠结。但他全力反对安茹作为伊丽莎白的潜在丈夫，称伊丽莎白在伦敦冒着引发第二次圣巴托罗缪大屠杀的风险。这话说得非常有力。不出所料，伊丽莎白大发雷霆。斯塔布斯最终因煽动叛乱而被砍掉了右手。
So that's a measure of, you know, you push Elizabeth too far. there's no nonsense about freedom of speech. You know, she's not having that. But some of her closest advisors, her chief cronies, are very, very opposed to the idea of this French marriage, aren't they? So, Walsingham, Robert Dudley. Yeah, the Earl of Leicester, yeah. And also on the Catholic side, there are also, there's massive opposition. So William Allen, the guy who had founded all the seminaries on the continent and kept sending Catholic priests over to England to try and subvert Elizabeth's regime.
所以，这衡量了你把伊丽莎白逼得太紧的后果，根本没有什么言论自由可言。你知道，她可不吃那一套。但她的一些最亲密的顾问，她的核心亲信，非常非常反对这场法国联姻，不是吗？比如沃尔辛厄姆，罗伯特·达德利。是的，莱斯特伯爵，是的。而且在天主教方面，也有巨大的反对声音。比如威廉·艾伦，那个在欧洲大陆建立了所有神学院，并不断派遣天主教神父到英国试图颠覆伊丽莎白政权的人。
kind of Elizabeth's greatest enemy among the English emigres, he thinks it's monstrous as well. And he explains it in terms of what he sees as the monstrousness of Elizabeth's depravity. So he writes a pamphlet in which he goes all in that Elizabeth is the little whore, the daughter of the great whore, Amber Lynn. And he said that he claimed that her desire for enjou was to the disgrace of princely majesty and the whole nation's reproach by unspeakable and incredible variety of love. lust, but it has to be emphasized. All of this is nonsense. The fact that Elizabeth is ready to accept enjie's blandishments owes nothing to lust, nor even to her undoubted fondness for him, because at stake are the needs of her kingdom, as Elizabeth understands them. She is using her virginity as a diplomatic tool. And if Elizabeth is facing a showdown with Spain, such a menacing
他是英国流亡者中伊丽莎白最大的敌人，他也认为这太荒谬了。他从他所认为的伊丽莎白堕落的怪异性来解释这一点。他写了一本小册子，全力抨击伊丽莎白是“小妓女”，是“大妓女”安妮·博林的女儿。他说，他声称她对安茹的渴望是对君主威严的羞辱，是对整个国家的亵渎，充满了难以言表的、不可思议的各种爱欲。但必须强调的是，这一切都是无稽之谈。伊丽莎白准备接受安茹的奉承，这与欲望无关，甚至与她对他毫无疑问的喜爱也无关，因为这关系到她王国的需求，正如伊丽莎白所理解的那样。她正在利用她的贞洁作为外交工具。如果伊丽莎白正面临与西班牙这个如此具有威胁性的
enemy, then Elizabeth thinks I might as well try and do all that I can to build bridges with the other great Catholic superpower, namely France. But even having said that, France isn't really the focus of her calculations. The real focus of her calculations is what's going on in the low countries, which by this point is an absolute dumpster fire. And why is it such a nightmare? What does the Duke of enjou have to do with it, in what way might enjou be a solution to the problem? Well, we need to move from France to the low countries and see what the state of play is there. So first of all, there is very good reason why ideological reason, religious reason, why Elizabeth and Protestants in England more generally should be alarmed by events in the Netherlands. We kind of compared
敌人的摊牌，那么伊丽莎白认为，我不如尽我所能与另一个伟大的天主教超级大国，即法国，建立联系。但即便如此，法国并不是她算计的真正焦点。她算计的真正焦点是低地国家正在发生的事情，那里此时此刻简直是一团糟。为什么那是一场噩梦？安茹公爵与此有什么关系？安茹在什么方面可能成为解决问题的方案？好吧，我们需要从法国转向低地国家，看看那里的局势如何。首先，伊丽莎白和英国的新教徒普遍对荷兰发生的事件感到惊恐，是有非常充分的理由的，意识形态上的理由，宗教上的理由。我们把它比作
it to, it's the Protestant Gaza. It's something that's calculated to alarm co-religionists in England. To remind people, this is where the local Protestants are in revolt against their Spanish overlords. And this war has been raging, fought very brutally. And the comparison with Gaza, it's become this kind of international story that strikes rage and fear and shock and outrage into the hearts of English Protestants. And Protestants look at the way that the Spanish troops in the low countries are repressing this revolt. And they say, you know, this is war crimes, it's genocide, it's absolute horror. These are the forces of Antichrist trampling down the godly and fertilizing the soil with their blood. And of course, it offers Protestants in England a glimpse of what their fate would be should Palmer and his 30,000 Spanish troops managed to cross the seas and land in England.
它是“新教的加沙”。这是为了让英国的共同信仰者感到惊恐。提醒人们，这就是当地新教徒反抗西班牙统治者的地方。这场战争一直在进行，打得非常残酷。与加沙的比较，它已经成为一种国际故事，在英国新教徒心中激起了愤怒、恐惧、震惊和义愤。新教徒看着低地国家的西班牙军队镇压这场起义的方式，他们说，你知道，这是战争罪，这是种族灭绝，这是绝对的恐怖。这些是敌基督的势力，践踏着虔诚的人，并用他们的鲜血肥沃了土地。当然，这也让英国的新教徒瞥见了如果帕尔马和他的3万西班牙军队设法跨海登陆英国，他们的命运将会如何。
And it's unsettling for them especially because Protestantism in the low countries is something that. has grown up organically, it's something that's kind of, it's not been top down as it was in England. So to quote Jonathan Israel, the great scholar of the low countries in this period, it had worked essentially from the bottom upwards instead of from government circles downwards. And so this had won it in the low countries, a kind of very unusually broad base sense of legitimacy, much broader than it had been in England. And it had made a clash with the very Catholic Philip of Spain, kind of inevitable, because Philip is ruling them. He is the Lord of the Netherlands. It's part of the kind of inheritance that he'd had from his father, the Charles
这对他们来说尤其令人不安，因为低地国家的新教是一种有机生长起来的东西，它不像在英国那样是自上而下的。引用低地国家这一时期伟大的学者乔纳森·以色列的话，它本质上是从底层向上运作的，而不是从政府圈子向下运作的。因此，这在低地国家为它赢得了某种非常罕见的广泛基础的合法性，比在英国要广泛得多。这使得与非常天主教的西班牙国王菲利普的冲突变得不可避免，因为菲利普统治着他们。他是荷兰的领主。这是他从他的父亲，伟大的哈布斯堡皇帝查理五世那里继承的一部分。
the 5th, the Great Habsburg Emperor. And so over the course of the 1560s, Philip had gone in really hard. So in 1565, he'd insisted on the full enforcement of heresy laws. In 1567, he'd sent a Spanish army to start pacifying the rebellious Protestant cities in the low countries. Thousands of Protestants had been executed as heretics. And in 1568, open warfare had broken out between the Spanish and the rebels against Philip's rules. And the fortunes of war had been seesawing this way and that for over a decade when the rebels in 1579 put out feelers to the Duke of Anjou. And their question is, would he accept the sovereignty of the low countries in place of Philip II? So they're not offering the crown. There isn't a kind of crown of the
因此，在16世纪60年代，菲利普采取了非常强硬的手段。1565年，他坚持全面执行异端法。1567年，他派遣了一支西班牙军队开始平定低地国家反叛的新教城市。成千上万的新教徒作为异端被处决。1568年，西班牙人和反抗菲利普统治的叛军之间爆发了公开战争。当叛军在1579年向安茹公爵试探时，战争的胜负已经摇摆不定了十多年。他们的问题是，他是否会接受低地国家的统治权以取代菲利普二世？所以他们不是在提供王冠。并没有所谓的低地国家的王冠，但他们是在说，你愿意取代菲利普成为低地国家的领主吗？安茹说，是的，我绝对愿意。我很乐意。那太棒了。你知道，他所有的兄弟都当过法国国王。他没说，他为什么不应该去当呢？经过旷日持久的谈判，他终于在虚线上签了字。1581年1月，安茹被正式宣布为荷兰的亲王和领主。1581年6月，这是欧洲乃至西方，包括美国，革命史上一个关键时刻，低地国家的总议会发布了一项废黜法案，正式放弃了西班牙国王及其继承人的统治。所以这是一个巨大的意识形态转折点，
low countries, but they're saying, would you become the lord of the low countries in place of Philip? And Anjou says, yeah, absolutely I would. I'd love to. That would be great. You know, all his brothers have been kings of France. He hasn't said, why shouldn't he go and be? And there'd been protracted negotiations and finally he had signed on the dotted line. And in January 1581, Anjou had been officially proclaimed the prince and the lord of the Netherlands. And in June 1581, a crucial moment in the history of kind of revolution more generally in Europe and the West, so including America, the states generals in the low countries had issued an act of abjuration formally renouncing the rule of the king of Spain and his heirs. So it's a kind of huge ideological turning point,
一个枢纽点。这是第一次发生这种情况，对吧？基本上是这样。一个代表人民的议会说我们正在抛弃我们的……是的。所以，你知道，你可以看出这会产生怎样的反响。1582年2月，安茹已经在英国了，但他认为，尽管伊丽莎白很有魅力，但她一直在欲擒故纵。这变得相当清楚了。她毕竟不会嫁给我。与其在英国闲逛，
a kind of pivot point. First time this has happened, right? Kind of basically, yeah. That an assembly speaking for the people says we are casting off our... Yeah. So, so, you know, you can see how this would reverberate. And in February 1582, Ojo has been in England, but he thinks that charming though Elizabeth is, she's playing hard to get. It's becoming pretty clear. She's not going to marry me after all. Rather than hang around in England,
我不如跨海去低地国家，在那里作为他们的领主进行统治。于是他离开了英国，事实证明这是伊丽莎白最后一次见到他。她骑马陪他穿过肯特郡，然后他在多佛登船，前往低地国家。现在，伊丽莎白和安茹之间的婚约
I am going to cross the sea and go to the low countries and rule there as their lord. And so he leaves England and Elizabeth, as it turns out for the last time. She rides with him through Kent, and then he takes ship from Dover, and he heads to the low countries. Now, the engagement between Elizabeth on Enjou
并没有解除。再次强调，这不是因为她看上了他。这是出于反西班牙外交的原因。她希望安茹在荷兰，因为尽管他是法国天主教徒，但他对英国来说，作为荷兰的领主，比西班牙的菲利普要好得多。实际上，让他成功地在低地国家建立统治将确保一系列英国的目标。这将导致帕尔马和他可怕的西班牙军队的撤离。我的意思是，那将是辉煌的。这也将恢复低地国家和英国之间的贸易联系，这是《历史的其余部分》多年来的主题之一，即英国在中世纪和16世纪与低地国家的贸易联系至关重要。运往布鲁日和
is not broken off. And again, just to emphasize, this isn't because she fancies him. It's for reasons of anti-Spanish diplomacy. She wants Anjou in the Netherlands because although he's a French Catholic, he's a better bet to be Lord of the Netherlands for England than Philip of Spain is. And actually having him establish his rule successfully in the low countries would secure a host of English objectives. So it would result in the removal of Palmer and his terrifying Spanish army. I mean, that would be brilliant. It would also restore trade links between the low countries in England, and it's been one of the themes of the rest is history over years that England's trade links with the low countries in the Middle Ages and in the 16th century are crucial. The wool that goes to Bruges and
根特，尤其是安特卫普的羊毛，真的非常非常重要。当然，还有整个“加沙”的事情，英国的新教徒和低地国家的新教徒之间存在一种天然的同情，因此确保新教徒的礼拜自由，这是安茹公爵所保证的，对他们来说将是一个绝对的胜利。这就是为什么伊丽莎白一直在追求安茹。这就是为什么她拉拢马奇蒙特去封德雷克为爵士。她是在向低地国家的双方发出信号，她支持安茹作为国王取代菲利普。当然，正如我们所说，她也正在给荷兰叛军提供一大笔钱，这些钱来自德雷克环球航行的收获。所以如果这能成功，那对伊丽莎白来说将是
Ghent and above all antwerp really, really matters. And of course, there's the whole kind of Gaza thing, the fact that Protestants in England and Protestants in the low countries, there's a natural sympathy between them and therefore securing freedom of worship for the Protestants, which the Duke of Anjou has guaranteed, would be an absolute win for them. And so this is why Elizabeth had been courting on Ju. It's why she co-opted Marchmont to Knight Drake. She's signaling to both sides in the low countries, her support for Anjou as king in Phillips Place. And also, of course, she is, you know, as we said, she's binging the Dutch rebels, a whole load of cash as well that has come from Drake's void around the world. So if only this can work out, it'll be
辉煌的。你知道，在各种战略层面上，这将是一场胜利。不幸的是，对她来说，这并没有成功。事实证明，她最后的婚约注定要失败。因为就在安茹抵达低地国家时，那里存在着不满的暗流。低地国家的两个关键州从一开始就拒绝接受他。这就是西兰和反叛州中最大的荷兰。他们说，我们不要安茹。荷兰和西兰本质上是新教抵抗运动的核心地带。他们根本不想要一位天主教亲王，即使他带着伊丽莎白的批准印章。与此同时，安茹，他并不真的只想做一个领主。他想成为荷兰的国王。因此，他对荷兰叛军强加给他的所有限制越来越恼火。1583年1月，他在安特卫普发动了一场未遂政变，安特卫普是低地国家的伟大经济、意识形态中心。它是欧洲远为富裕的城市，
brilliant for Elizabeth. You know, in all kinds of strategic ways, it will be a victory. Unfortunately for her, it does not work out. And what will prove to be her last engagement is actually doomed. Because even as Anjou arrives in the low countries, there is there an undertow of discontent. And two crucial states in the low countries have refused to accept him from the start. And these are Zealand and the largest of the rebel states, Holland. They say, we are not having enjou. And Holland and Zealand are essentially the heartlands of the Protestant resistance. And they just do not want a Catholic prince, even if he comes with Elizabeth's seal of approval. And meanwhile, enjou, he doesn't really just want to be a lord. He wants to be the king of the Netherlands. And so he's becoming increasingly annoyed by all the restrictions that have been placed on him by the Dutch rebels. And in January 1583, he launches an attempted coup in Antwerp, which is the great economic, ideological powerhouse of the low countries. It's by far the richer city in Europe,
很可能是世界上最富裕的。它和巴黎一样大。它比伦敦大得多。它是这个新兴全球经济的伟大市场。所以如果安茹能夺取安特卫普的控制权，那么他身后就会有大量的现金。也许他真的可以着手让自己成为荷兰的国王，而不仅仅是领主。不幸的是，对他来说，事情变得非常糟糕。他的民兵在后来被称为“法国狂暴”的事件中被消灭了。由于那次失败，他在低地国家的前景注定要失败。到了六月，他已经离开前往法国，再也没有回来。他回到了妈咪，凯瑟琳·德·美第奇身边，这是一个非常可怕的人物。她完全是冷嘲热讽。她对他说，愿上帝让你早点死，那样你就不会
quite possibly the world. It's as large as Paris. It's much larger than. London. It's the great marketplace of this emerging global economy. And so if enjou can seize control of Antwerp, then he will have a lot of cash behind him. And perhaps he really can set about making himself king rather than just lord of the low countries. Unfortunately for him, it goes horribly wrong. His militia are wiped out in what becomes known as the French fury. And as a result of that defeat, his prospects in the low countries are doomed. And by June, he has left for France and he never returns. And he goes back to Mummy, Catherine de Meditry, very formidable figure. And she is completely withering. And she says to him, would to God you had died young, you would not then have
成为那么多勇敢绅士死亡的原因了。哇。那真是……嘘。所以，任何想要为让她们失望的儿子寻求育儿建议的母亲们，听着并学习吧。伊丽莎白也反应非常强烈。她解除了婚约。因此，那次确保在低地国家击败西班牙的尝试被阻断了。安茹，你知道，他不会在那里建立他的统治。就在她一直在操纵让安茹在荷兰就位的同时，她的天主教敌人也一直在进行操纵。即使在她的枢密院和政府眼中，伊丽莎白的注意力集中在低地国家，一个新的阴谋正在法国酝酿。这是一个新的阴谋，但它的目标对于听过我们早期剧集的人来说会非常熟悉。这些目标是天主教入侵英国，推翻伊丽莎白，用玛丽·斯图亚特取代伊丽莎白成为女王。正如伯利在伦敦的情报主管所说，当这个阴谋的第一丝风声开始传到伯利的特工耳中时，他写信给伯利勋爵说，敌人并未沉睡。不祥之兆。所以休息后回来，看看这个新阴谋会发生什么。本集由克劳德·比安特罗皮克为您呈现。
been the cause of death of so many brave gentlemen. Wow. That's hush. So any mothers out there wanting parenting tips for sons who let them down, listen and learn. And Elizabeth also reacts very harshly. She breaks off the engagement. So that attempt to secure the defeat of the Spanish in the low countries is blocked. Enjou is, you know, he's not going to establish his rule there. And all the while she's been maneuvering to get enjou in place in the Netherlands. Her Catholic enemies likewise have been on maneuvers. And even as Elizabeth in the eyes of her privy council and government are fixed on the low countries, a new conspiracy is brewing in France. And it's a new conspiracy, but it is a conspiracy with goals that will be very familiar to people who've been
最近我不得不处理各种各样的问题。其中之一是不得不写一个关于1915年第一次世界大战的系列。被这些东西淹没太容易了，就像一个意大利士兵蹒跚地爬上一座石灰岩山，走向奥地利的枪口。虽然意大利人在那场战役中经常感到孤独，但我知道我总是有你。这非常特别。你确实，主宰了。
listening to our early episode. These goals are a Catholic invasion of England, the toppling of Elizabeth, the replacement of Elizabeth as Queen by Mary Stewart. And as Burley's head of intelligence in London puts it, writing to Lord Burley as the first kind of whiff of this conspiracy starts reaching the noses of Burley's intelligence agents, the enemy sleeps not. Ominous. So come back after the break to find out what happens with this new conspiracy. This episode is brought to you by Claude Bianthropic.
是的。如果我必须独自完成它，我可能会感到畏缩。我从未感到孤独，但有时人们确实会感到孤独。好消息是，当你需要帮助思考问题时，有克劳德。克劳德是为那些不满足于“足够好”的头脑而设计的AI。它是真正理解你整个工作流程并与你一起思考的合作者。所以无论你是在午夜调试代码，还是在策划你的下一个商业举措，克劳德都能扩展你的思维，以解决重要的问题。
Recently I've had to work through all kinds of issues. One of them was having to write a series about the First World War in 1915. It would have been so easy to be overwhelmed by that, like an Italian soldier trudging up a limestone hill towards Austrian guns. Whereas the Italians often felt alone in that campaign, I knew that I always had you. It was very special. You did, dominate.
对于值得解决的问题，请在 clod.aI/rest is history 开始使用克劳德。那是 claude.a.ai/rest is history。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克 Optic 是 2025 年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。在无缝的 33 英寸显示屏和沉浸式的 19 扬声器 AKG 环绕音响系统中找到你的节奏。这座城市需要敏捷性，而 Optic 以精准交付，让每一次驾驶都非同寻常。让我们开凯迪拉克吧。在 Cadillac Canada.ca 了解更多信息。豪华销售声明基于标普全球移动 2025 日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克的豪华定义。
Yeah. And if I'd had to do it on my own, I'd have probably been daunted. I never felt alone, but sometimes people do feel alone. And the good news is that when you need help thinking through a problem, there's Claude. Claude is the AI for minds that don't stop at good enough. It's the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and thinks with you. So whether you're debugging code at midnight or strategizing your next business move, Claude extends your thinking to tackle the problems that matter.
来自《超级骑警》和《超级骑警 2》的制片人，你猜对了。破碎蜥蜴和他们吵闹的巡逻队回到了犯罪现场。在《超级骑警 3》中，胡子更浓密，枫糖浆更粘稠，恶作剧比以往任何时候都更疯狂。系好安全带，迎接夏天最有趣的喜剧。 《超级骑警 3》，周五仅在影院上映。立即购票。欢迎大家回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是 1583 年 6 月。想象一下这个场景。我们在巴黎，一群世界上最糟糕的人在开会。由吉斯公爵领导，所以这是，
For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI slash rest is history. That's claude.a.ai slash rest is history. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19 speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury.
如果你还记得的话，他由麦斯·米科尔森扮演。他是法国天主教联盟的领袖。他是苏格兰玛丽女王的表弟。他是一个多年来一直致力于推翻伊丽莎白·都铎，伊丽莎白一世，乃至英国新教的人。所以是一个绝对可怕的人。汤姆，当我们通过这个故事的英雄，伯利勋爵和弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士的眼睛来看待这一切时，这就像《白头神探》的开场，不是吗？
From the producers of Super Troopers and Super Troopers 2 comes, you guessed it. Broken Lizard and their rowdy patrol squad returned to the scene of the crime. In Super Troopers 3, the mustaches are thicker, the maple syrup stickier, and the pranks crazier than ever. Buckle up for the funniest comedy of the summer. Super Troopers 3, only in theaters Friday. Get tickets now. Welcome back, everybody, to the rest is history. It is June 1583. Picture the scene. We are in Paris, a meeting of some of the worst people in the world. Led by the Duke of Gies, so this is,
当你有了阿亚图拉，有了米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫，有了卡扎菲上校，还有所有其他警察小队的弗兰克·德雷宾必须面对的恶棍，这基本上就是那个场景，因为除了吉斯公爵之外，还有谁在那里？所以吉斯在那里。他有他的军事和精神顾问。如果你是一个虔诚的新教徒，你知道，吉斯公爵的军事和精神顾问都是可怕的人。威廉·艾伦，流亡英国天主教徒的首领。不，他是个坏人。是的。教皇在巴黎的使节。哦，得了吧。猜猜更糟。
he's been played, if you recall, by Mads Mikkelson. He is the leader of the Catholic League in France. He is the cousin of Mary Queen of Scots. He is a man who has committed, has been committed for years to the overthrow of Elizabeth Tudor, Elizabeth I, and indeed Protestantism in England. So an absolutely terrible man. And Tom, as we look on this through the eyes of the heroes of this story, Lord Birdley and Sir Francis Walsingham, it's like the opening of the naked gun, isn't it?
还有格拉斯哥大主教，一个叫詹姆斯·比顿的人，他实际上在巴黎担任玛丽·斯图亚特的大使，也就是苏格兰玛丽女王。真是个恐怖室。是的。我的意思是，如果你是沃尔辛厄姆，这就是你所有的噩梦都在一个房间里。所以吉斯一直渴望入侵英国。我们之前谈过这个。你知道，他是苏格兰玛丽女王的表弟。所以如果他能娶苏格兰玛丽女王，那就太棒了。他将成为英国国王，也许还有苏格兰国王。但让他现在推动这项冒险的原因是他获得了两个关键盟友的支持。
When you've got the Ayatollah and you've got Mikhail Gorbachev and you've got Colonel Gaddafi and all these other villains that Frank Drebben of police squad has to confront, this is basically the scene, because who, are the people who are there, apart from this, apart from the Duke of Gies? So Gies is there. He's got his military and spiritual advisors. And if you're a devout Protestant, you know, the military and spiritual advisors of the Duke of Gies are terrible people. William Allen, the head of the English Catholics in exile. No, he's a bad man. Yeah. The Pope's nuncio in Paris. Oh, come on. Guess worse.
第一个是教皇，所以才有了使节的出席，但更关键的是门多萨，那个我们在本集前面提到的，在伦敦的脾气暴躁且非常激进地反新教的西班牙大使。所以有了教皇和英国西班牙大使的支持，事情看起来非常有希望。在这次会议上制定了一个非常详细的计划。决定 12,000 名士兵将从法国启航前往英格兰西北部，也就是兰开夏郡，这是英格兰最天主教的地区。资金将在入侵前被送去，以鼓励兰开夏郡的天主教徒为起义做好准备。这些资金将由吉斯本人提供，
And the Archbishop of Glasgow, a guy called James Beaton, who is effectively functioning as Mary Stuart's ambassador in Paris, so the Mary Queen of Scots. What a chamber of horrors. Yeah. I mean, if you're Walsingham, this is all your nightmares in one room. So Gies has been hankering to invade England for ages. We talked about this earlier. You know, he's the cousin of Mary Queen of Scott. So if he can marry Mary Queen of Scots, be brilliant. He'll become King of England and maybe King of Scotland as well. But what makes him push the venture now is that he has secured the backing of two crucial allies.
但也由菲利普二世和教皇提供。所以从伯利和沃尔辛厄姆的角度来看，这是一种邪恶的三位一体。与此同时，第二支较小的部队将穿过海峡并在萨塞克斯登陆，也就是在英格兰南部。在这里，他们将与诺森伯兰伯爵和阿伦德尔伯爵联手，他们都是天主教徒，而且他们的城堡都位于离这次入侵部队预定登陆地点很近的地方。吉斯对这一切有多认真，这不仅仅是一个白日梦，他真的打算让它继续进行，一个迹象是，在制定计划的这次会议后的下个月，他前往诺曼底，在那里，你知道，他开始为这次海峡穿越做准备。
The first of these is the Pope, so hence the presence of the nuncio there, but also crucially of Mendoza, who is the choleric and very aggressively anti-protestant Spanish ambassador in London, who we met earlier in this episode. So with the backing of the Pope and the Spanish ambassador in England, things are looking very promising. And a very detailed plan is drawn up at this meeting. And it's decided that 12,000 troops will set sail from France for, northwest England, so that's Lancashire, which is the most Catholic region of England. And funds will have been sent ahead of the invasion to encourage the Catholics in Lancashire to prepare themselves for revolt. And these funds are to be provided by Gies himself,
现在，没有好的情报，这一切都不会奏效。因此，在入侵准备的这个阶段，计划大多是在阴影中进行的。吉斯正在资助一些特工。其中一些他正在秘密派遣穿过海峡。另一些已经居住在英国，并从伦敦的法国大使馆受到控制。在这些已经身处英国的特工中，关键特工是一个名叫弗朗西斯·思罗克莫顿的年轻天主教绅士。他出身名门。他关系广泛。他的叔叔曾作为伊丽莎白的大使服务于苏格兰和法国。但不幸的是，弗朗西斯自己的
but also by Philip II and by the Pope. So the kind of unholy Trinity from the point of Burleigh and Walsingham. Meanwhile, a second smaller force will cross the channel and land in Sussex, so that is in southern England. And here they will team up with the earls of Northumberland and Arendall, who are both Catholic and both have castles located conveniently nearby the projected landing place for this invasion force. And the sign of how seriously Gies is taking all this, this isn't just a pipe dream. He really is intending that it should go ahead, is that the following month after this meeting where the plans have been drawn up, he heads to Normandy, where he is, you know, he sets himself preparing for this channel crossing.
家庭陷入了困境。所以弗朗西斯的父亲是一名律师和皇家官员，但他于 1580 年去世，身上背负着腐败交易的指控和一笔对他征收的巨额罚款。所以这对弗朗西斯来说是一份非常糟糕的遗产。最重要的是，弗朗西斯一直被他的母亲秘密抚养为天主教徒。所以他身无分文且是天主教徒。换句话说，正是那种容易成为吉斯特工的人，因为这服务于他的意识形态，也服务于他的经济利益。没错。正是思罗克莫顿将当时在约克郡被软禁的玛丽·斯图亚特，也就是苏格兰玛丽女王，与伦敦的阴谋者和巴黎的阴谋者联系起来。
Now, none of this will work without good intelligence. And so at this stage of the preparations for the invasion, the plans are mostly being conducted in the shadows. And Geese is sponsoring a number of agents. And some of these he is sending undercover across the channel. And others are already resident in England and being controlled from the French embassy. in London. And the key agent among these agents who are already in England is a young Catholic gentleman called Francis Throckmorton. He's very well born. He's well connected. His uncle had served Elizabeth as her ambassador to both Scotland and France. But unfortunately, Francis's own
所以他是他们所有人之间的中间人。没错。因此后来被称为“思罗克莫顿阴谋”。所以伦敦的阴谋，这个阴谋的总部，实际上是西班牙大使馆，我想，西班牙大使，门多萨，我们已经谈过他了。他这种人，我的意思是，他就像来自某种新教选角机构的人物。是的，噩梦。是的，没错。他恨伊丽莎白。他恨弗朗西斯·德雷克。他恨英国。他只是一个可怕的人。然后另一个人是法国大使，他叫米歇尔·德·卡斯特诺。他比那个西班牙人更精于算计，更圆滑，更微妙，不是吗？是的，而且他在那里待了很长时间。所以他于 1572 年被派往那里，并被特别指派
family has fallen on hard times. So Francis's father is a lawyer and a royal official, but he died in 1580 with a kind of accusation of corrupt dealings hanging over his head and a massive fine that's been kind of levied against him. So this is a very bad patrimony for Francis to inherit. And on top of that, Francis has been secretly raised by his mother as a Catholic. So he's skint and a Catholic. In other words, exactly the kind of person who is liable to become an agent for Gies because it serves his ideological, but also his financial. interests. Right. And it's Throck Morton who links up Mary Stewart, who is under house arrest in Yorkshire at the time, so Mary Queen of Scots, the conspirators in London and the conspirators
在圣巴托罗缪大屠杀后缓和英法关系。所以他因其圆滑以及其他品质而被选中。他做得非常好。所以到了 1583 年，他在处理与伊丽莎白及其政府的关系方面已经有了十多年的经验。伊丽莎白不是一个容易对付的女人。我的意思是，你知道，她把游戏玩得很好。但一直以来，我很遗憾地说，卡斯特诺一直与苏格兰玛丽女王保持着密切联系，
in Paris. So he is the kind of the go-between between them all. Right. Hence the Throck-Morton plot, as it's later known. So the conspiracy in London, the headquarters of this conspiracy, effectively the Spanish embassy, I guess, the Spanish ambassador, Mendoza, we already talked about him. He's this sort of, I mean, he's like a figure from a kind of Protestant casting agency. Yeah, nightmare. Yeah, exactly. He hates Elizabeth. He hates Francis Drake. He hates England. He's just a terrible person. And then the other person is the French ambassador, and he is called Michel de Castell-Lieu. And he is much more calculating and smoother and more subtle, isn't he, than the Spanish guy? Yes, and he's been there a long time. So he'd been sent in 1572 and charged
她使用密码给他写信。令人惊讶的是，她的一批信件直到 2024 年才在法国国家图书馆被发现。它们确凿地表明，苏格兰玛丽女王并不是这场阴谋中的被动旁观者。你知道，她不仅仅是被吉斯为了自己的利益而使用的密码。她实际上是这场阴谋中的积极参与者。是的。所以这几十年来，几个世纪以来一直被历史学家争论。
specifically with smoothing Anglo-French relations after the St. Bartholomew's Day Massacre. So he's been chosen for his emoliency among other qualities. And he's done a very good job. And so by 583, he's got over a decade's worth of experience in handling relations with Elizabeth and her government. And Elizabeth is not an easy woman to handle. I mean, you know, she plays the game very well. But the whole while, I'm sad to say, Castelnaud has been in close contact with Mary Queen of Scots,
是的。玛丽是被陷害的吗？你知道，她是被更马基雅维利式的人利用了吗？她是天真的吗？还是，你知道，她加入了阴谋？她是一个积极的参与者，确切地说是阴谋中的积极特工吗？基本上，最近的证据表明毫无疑问。是的，确实如此。
who is writing to him using a cipher. And amazingly, a cache of her letters were found as recently as 2024 in the Bibliatech Nacional de France. And they show conclusively the Mary Queen of Scots is not a passive bystander in this. You know, she's not just a cipher being used by Gies for his own interest. She was actually an active conspirator in this plot. Yeah. So this has been debated by historians. for decades for centuries.
她非常清楚自己在做什么。她卷起袖子。她全身心投入。是的。因此，法国大使在索尔兹伯里法院的住所，那是一座非常宏伟的房子或弗利特街，这使它成为吉斯策划的阴谋的关键焦点。
Yeah. Was Mary effectively framed? You know, was she being used by more Machiavellian people? Was she naive? Or was, you know, did she join in the plots? Was she an act, exactly an active agent in the conspiracy? And basically, this recent evidence suggests there's no question whatsoever. Yes, it does.
你知道，他，他，本质上，它是英国境内行动的神经中枢。没错。然而，伊丽莎白的伟大间谍头子沃尔辛厄姆，一直以来都在索尔兹伯里法院的法国大使馆里有鼹鼠。其中一个代号为“亨利·法戈特”。很棒的代号。
She knew exactly what she was doing. She'd rolled up her sleeves. She got stuck in. Yeah. And so a result of this, the residency of the French, Ambassador, Salisbury Court, which is a house or very grand house or Fleet Street, this makes it a kind of key focus of the conspiracy that is being
这个鼹鼠的身份非常有争议。所以 1991 年，这些主题的伟大历史学家约翰·博西出版了一本书，认为这个鼹鼠，亨利·法戈特，实际上是文艺复兴哲学中一个非常非常著名的名字。这是一个那不勒斯修士，他变成了一种自然哲学家。他成为了一名赫尔墨斯魔法师。这个人的名字是焦尔达诺·布鲁诺。哦，是的，非常大的名字。是的。所以布鲁诺最终成为了泛神论者。
hatched by Geese. You know, he, he, essentially, it's the nerve centre for operations within England itself. Right. However, Walsingham, the great spy chief of Elizabeth, all along has had moles in the French embassy in Salisbury Court. And one of them goes by the code name of Henry Faggot. Great code name.
他是三位一体的怀疑论者。他怀疑基督的神性。所以，你知道，各种异端的全套自助餐。他非常严重地主张无限宇宙和外星生命的可能性。所以是外星人想法的忠实粉丝。他最终将于 1600 年在罗马被宗教裁判所烧死，那里有一座著名的布鲁诺雕像，他被誉为言论自由的烈士。
And the identity of this mole is very controversial. So in 1991, the great historian of these topics, John Bossy, he published a book arguing that this mole, Henry Faggart, had actually been a very, very famous name in Renaissance philosophy. And this was a Neapolitan friar who had turned a kind of philosopher of nature. He'd become a hermetic magician. And the name of this guy is Giadano Bruno. Oh, yeah, very big name. Yeah. So Bruno ends up becoming a pantheist.
我的意思是，我不认为他真的是那样。他的信仰对我们来说太文艺复兴了，你知道，太奇怪了，但他是一个非常有力量、有魅力、迷人的人物。所以他可能是沃尔辛厄姆在索尔兹伯里法院的鼹鼠，这太令人惊讶了。如果亨利·法戈特是布鲁诺，那么休·特雷弗·罗珀在评论博西的书时说，他选择了他的化名，带有先见之明的冷幽默，因为当然，柴火会被用来烧死他。当然。但他为什么要为了钱这样做呢？
He is a skeptic about the Trinity. He doubts the divinity of Christ. So, you know, the full smorgasbord of heresies. And he very grievily argued for an infinite universe and the possibility of life in outer space. So a big fan of the idea of aliens. And he would end up being burned in 1600 in Rome by, the Inquisition and there is a famous statue of Bruno there and he's kind of celebrated as a martyr
我想是为了钱吧。你知道，他在那里。他在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。他于 1583 年担任法国大使的秘书。但必须说，博西的论点并没有被普遍接受。事实上，我认为大多数历史学家可能不接受它。原因在于证据完全是间接的。你知道，这只是，你可以说这都只是巧合。
for freedom of speech. I mean, I don't think he was really that. His beliefs were kind of two Renaissance really, you know, by our lights too strange, but he's a very powerful, charismatic, fascinating figure. So it's amazing the possibility that he was Walsingham's mole in Salisbury Court. And if Henry Faggart was Bruno, then there's Hugh Trevor Roper in his review of Bossy's book said he'd chosen his pseudonym with prescient grim humor because of course faggots would be used to burn him. Of course. But why would he, why would he have done it for money?
但无论法戈特是谁，他都是第一个向沃尔辛厄姆指认思罗克莫顿是间谍的人。于是沃尔辛厄姆随后在大使馆招募了另一名鼹鼠，我们不知道这是谁，但有人比法戈特更接近卡斯特诺。他为沃尔辛厄姆提供了玛丽和卡斯特诺之间实际通信的副本。到了 1583 年 6 月，也就是吉斯在巴黎召开会议策划入侵的时候，玛丽已经担心沃尔辛厄姆盯上了思罗克莫顿，她使用密码写信给法国大使馆，给那里的大使说出了这一点。
For I suppose it would have been for money. You know, he is there. He's in the right place at the right time. He is serving as the French ambassador's secretary in 1583. But it has to be said that Bossie's argument has not been universally accepted. In fact, I think probably most historians don't accept it. And the reason for that is that the evidence is entirely circumstantial. You know, it's just, you could say it's all just coincidence.
而且，你知道，她没猜错，因为沃尔辛厄姆确实在监视思罗克莫顿与卡斯特诺以及门多萨的会面。所以即使阴谋正在进行，沃尔辛厄姆也在监视每一个步骤。然后他出击了，不是吗？他等啊等啊等。然后在 11 月 7 日出击。实际上思罗克莫顿被他们抓了个现行。是的，正在编码一封给玛丽的信。
But whoever faggot is, he is the one who first fingers Strop Morton as a spy to Walsingham. And so Walsingham then recruits another mole in the embassy, and we have no idea who this was, but someone who is much closer to Castelnau than whoever faggot was. And he provides Walsingham with copies of the actual corrosy, correspondence between Mary and Castelnau. And by June 1583, so this is exactly the time when Gis is convening his meeting in Paris to plot the invasion, Mary is already anxious that Walsingham is on to Throckmorton, and she writes using her cipher to the French embassy, to the ambassador there to say as much.
编码一封信。他们冲进去逮捕了他。是的。所以他被带到塔楼，在那里他被施以酷刑。他非常勇敢。他拒绝说话。我的意思是，他遭受了极度的折磨。但沃尔辛厄姆，他说，尽管他表现出了罗马式的决心，我，换句话说，他准备忍受死亡而不是说出他的想法。沃尔辛厄姆说他会。他遭受了太多
And, you know, she's not wrong because Walsingham is indeed monitoring Throckmorton's meetings with Kustlenow and also with Mendoza. So even as the plot is going ahead, Walsingham is watching every last step. And then he pounces, doesn't he? He waits and waits and waits. Then he pounces on the 7th of November. And actually Throckmorton is, they catch him red-handed. Yeah, encoding a letter to Mary.
痛苦。你知道，他，沃尔辛厄姆更令人不寒而栗的事情之一是，他理解痛苦的心理，他是对的，因为三天后，到那时思罗克莫顿已经有时间恢复了，囚犯被带回刑架，看到它。他只是屈服了。他跪倒在地。他做出了忏悔。阴谋的所有细节都出来了，吉斯、法国大使馆的卡斯特诺、西班牙大使馆的门多萨，以及关键的苏格兰玛丽女王的参与。正是最后的忏悔，玛丽一直以叛国语气与他通信的忏悔，让思罗克莫顿感到最痛苦。所以他大喊，现在我背叛了她，这个世界上我最亲爱的人。
Coding a letter. And they burst in and arrest him. Yeah. And so he's taken to the tower where he is put to the rack. He's very brave. he refuses to speak. I mean, he suffers excruciating torture. But Walsingham, he says, notwithstanding the great show that he hath made of a Roman resolution, I, in other words, he's prepared to suffer death rather than speak his mind. Walsingham says he will. He suffered too
既然我对她的信仰失败了，我不在乎我是否被绞死。这很好，因为他确实被绞死了。嗯，不仅仅是绞死。我的意思是，这比绞死更糟，对吧？是的。所以他在 1584 年 5 月受审。他确实撤回了他的忏悔。他说，你知道，我只是因为遭受了太大的痛苦才这么做的。
much pain. You know, he, one of the more chilling things about Walsingham, he understands the psychology of pain and he's right, because three days later, you know, by which time Throckmorton's been given time to recover, the prisoner is led back to the rack and the sight of it. He just gives way. He falls to his knees. He makes his confession. And all the details of the plot come out, the involvement of Gies of Castlenau in the French embassy of Mendoza in the Spanish embassy, and crucially of Mary Queen of Scots. And it's the last confession, the confession that Mary has been corresponding in treasonous tones with him that causes Throck Morton the most agony. So he cries out, now I have betrayed her, who was dearest to me in this world.
但这没用。他当然因叛国罪被定罪。因此，他遭受了叛徒的命运。他于 7 月 10 日在泰伯恩被绞死、拖行并分尸。他死时拒绝请求女王的原谅，这在传统上人们会这样做，因为那样他们的亲属和继承人会得到更好的对待。他拒绝那样做。从沃尔辛厄姆的角度来看，你知道，这是一次辉煌的间谍活动。它产生了巨大巨大的后果。所以让我们看看后果，让我们看看参与阴谋的各种人，阿亚图拉，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫等等。以及对他们有什么后果。所以让我们从吉斯公爵开始。所以这是麦斯·米科尔森的角色。所以他起初，在思罗克莫顿被揭露后，那并没有让他感到困惑。他继续他的计划，不是吗？
And since I have failed with my faith towards her, I care not if I were hanged. And that's just as well because he is hanged. Well, more than hanged. I mean, it's worse than hanging, right? Yeah. So he's tried in May 1584. And he does retract his confession. And he says, you know, I only made it because I'd suffered such pain.
是的，所以苏格兰玛丽女王设法给他送去了一封信。她非常热衷于阴谋应该继续下去。她曾是法国女王。所以她从她的嫁妆中留下了一些投资。她说，好吧，你可以用那里的钱来帮助继续资助阴谋。这就是吉斯想听到的。所以他说，好吧，没问题，我们继续。但随后阴谋确实被挫败了。
But it doesn't help. He is convicted for treason, of course. And so therefore he suffers at traitor's fate. He's hung, drawn and courted at Tyburn on the 10th of July. And he dies refusing to ask for the Queen's forgiveness, which traditionally people would do because then their relatives and heirs would be treated better. He refuses to do that. From Walsingham's point of view, it's, you know, it's been brilliant.
但这无济于事。他当然被判叛国罪。因此，他遭受了叛徒的命运。7月10日，他在泰伯恩被处以绞刑、剖腹和分尸。他死时拒绝请求女王的原谅，而按照传统，人们通常会这样做，因为这样他们的亲属和继承人会受到更好的对待。他拒绝这样做。在沃尔辛厄姆看来，这真是太精彩了。
It's been a completely triumphant feat of Spycraft. And it has massive, massive consequences. So let's look at the consequences and let's go through the various people who were involved in the plot, as it were, the Ayatollah, Mikhail Gorbachev and so on. And what the consequences are for them. So let's start with the Duke of Geese. So this is the Mads-Mickleson character. So he at first, after Throckmorton's unmasking, that doesn't throw him. He continues with his planning, doesn't he?
这是一场极其成功的间谍杰作。它产生了巨大、巨大的影响。让我们看看这些后果，并逐一了解参与阴谋的各色人等，比如阿亚图拉、米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫等等。以及这对他们意味着什么。让我们从吉斯公爵开始。这就是那个麦斯·米科尔森式的角色。在斯罗克莫顿被揭穿后，他起初并没有被吓倒。他继续他的计划，不是吗？
Yeah, so Mary Queen of Scots manages to get a letter through to him. And she is very keen that the plot should carry on. And she had been Queen of France. And so she kind of has investments left from her dowry. And she says, well, you could use money from that to help continue fund the plot. And that's what Gies wants to hear. So he says, fine, okay, we'll carry on. But then the plot does get knocked on the head.
是的，苏格兰玛丽女王设法给他送去了一封信。她非常渴望阴谋能继续下去。她曾是法国王后，所以她还保留着一些嫁妆投资。她说，好吧，你可以用那笔钱来继续资助这个阴谋。这正是吉斯想听到的。所以他说，好吧，没问题，我们会继续。但随后这个阴谋还是被挫败了。
And it's nothing that Walsinger or the English do. It's the fact that on the 10th of June, 1584, the Duke of Vangue, so Elizabeth's frog, you know, this guy who'd been courting him, the guy who had messed up being the Lord of the Netherlands. He dies from malaria at the age of 29. And this is fateful because it means with the Duke of enchu, Henry III, so Andrew Scott, the King of France, he has no air. So with his death, the House of Alwa will go extinct. And the next in line is Henry of Navarre, Pedro Pascal, who is the Huguenot, the Protestant. And this is plainly intolerable.
这并不是沃尔辛厄姆或英国人所为。事实是，1584年6月10日，安茹公爵，也就是伊丽莎白的“青蛙”，那个一直追求她、搞砸了荷兰领主身份的家伙，因疟疾去世，年仅29岁。这非常关键，因为这意味着随着安茹公爵的去世，法国国王亨利三世，也就是安德鲁·斯科特，将后继无人。因此，随着他的死亡，瓦卢瓦王朝将绝嗣。而王位的第一顺位继承人是纳瓦拉的亨利，也就是佩德罗·帕斯卡，他是胡格诺派，也就是新教徒。这显然是无法容忍的。
So just as it's intolerable for Protestants in England that Elizabeth should be succeeded by the Catholic Mary, so is it intolerable for Gies and the Catholics in France that Henry III should be succeeded by the Protestant Henry of Navarre. So his entire focus now is on ensuring that this will never happen. And so the kingdom collapses back into civil war. It's known in France as the War of the Three Henrys, which I think is one of the great names for a war at any time. And basically, France will be so consumed by its own agonies that no one there is going to have much time for affairs in England.
正如英国的新教徒无法容忍伊丽莎白由天主教徒玛丽继位一样，法国的吉斯家族和天主教徒也无法容忍亨利三世由新教徒纳瓦拉的亨利继位。所以他现在的全部重心就是确保这种情况永远不会发生。于是，王国再次陷入内战。在法国，这被称为“三亨利之战”，我认为这是历史上最伟大的战争名称之一。基本上，法国将因自身的痛苦而精疲力竭，以至于那里没有人有太多时间去处理英国的事务。
So that basically is the French now knocked out of calculations. There remains, of course, the Spanish, and in particular Mendoza, the Spanish ambassador, who's up to his eyeballs in all this plotting. And so on the 19th of January 1584, he was summoned to meet the Privy Council and Walsingham, in his fluent Italian, lists six charges of conspiracy against him and informs him that he is going to be expelled. Mendoza very angrily and menacingly denies the charges and he says Don Bernardino Mendoza was born not to disturb kingdoms, but to conquer them. Wow. However, that said, he is being expelled. He has no choice but to pack his bags. And this is a decisive moment in Anglo-Spanish relations because no one is sent to replace him.
所以，法国人基本上被排除在计算之外了。当然，还剩下西班牙人，特别是西班牙大使门多萨，他深陷于所有这些阴谋之中。因此，在1584年1月19日，他被传唤去见枢密院，沃尔辛厄姆用流利的意大利语列举了他六项阴谋罪名，并通知他将被驱逐。门多萨非常愤怒且带有威胁性地否认了这些指控，他说唐·贝纳迪诺·门多萨生来不是为了扰乱王国，而是为了征服它们。哇。然而，话虽如此，他还是被驱逐了。他别无选择，只能收拾行李。这是英西关系中的一个决定性时刻，因为没有人被派来接替他。
Effectively, England and Spain now have no diplomatic relations. And so it is becoming much harder for the two sides to communicate. So that's Mendoza gone. Right. So what about the best-known person in this conspiracy? the person on whom the conspiracy really hinges. What about Mary Queen of Scots? Well, she denies all the charges against her, and she insists quite correctly that she had written none of the letters carried by Throckmorton because they'd been written by her
实际上，英国和西班牙现在没有外交关系了。因此，双方沟通变得更加困难。门多萨走了。那么，这个阴谋中最著名的人，也就是阴谋真正所系的人，苏格兰女王玛丽呢？好吧，她否认了所有针对她的指控，并非常正确地坚持认为，她没有写过任何由思罗克莫顿携带的信件，因为那些信是由她的
secretaries, and she says, I knew absolutely nothing about them. There is also a problem for Walsingham and Burley, should they want to prosecute Mary, because remember that Throck Morton at his trial had said that he had confessed under-July. duress because of the pain of the rack. And under English law, that invalidates his evidence. And of course, always lurking in the background is the biggest problem of all, which is that Mary is a sovereign queen and that therefore Elizabeth refuses to countenance the possibility of her being executed. And also, Mary can quite reasonably say, well, I can't be accused of treason because as a sovereign Queen, how can I possibly be a subject of Elizabeth? And, you know, that is a very valid legal
秘书写的，她说，我对此一无所知。对于沃尔辛厄姆和伯利来说，如果他们想起诉玛丽，还有一个问题，因为请记住，思罗克莫顿在审判时曾说，他是因为酷刑的痛苦而被迫招供的。根据英国法律，这使他的证据无效。当然，背景中一直潜伏着最大的问题，那就是玛丽是一位主权女王，因此伊丽莎白拒绝考虑处决她的可能性。而且，玛丽也可以非常合理地说，好吧，我不能被指控犯有叛国罪，因为作为一位主权女王，我怎么可能是伊丽莎白的臣民呢？而且，你知道，这是一个非常有效的法律
point. Yeah. And this all along has been the great imponderable problem for Burley and Walsingham. Mary left alive is clearly a massive, massive threat to Elizabeth. The fact that she is Catholic and Elizabeth's most obvious air is a constant incentive to Catholic dissidents to try and assassinate Elizabeth or otherwise remove her from the throne. But Elizabeth will not countenance her removal and the legal apparatus for doing it doesn't exist. But the impact of the Throckmorton plot on Burley and Walsingham is absolutely massive because they are now absolutely set on eliminating Mary Queen of Scots no matter what it costs. No matter what the legal costs, no matter what the diplomatic costs, no matter what the costs in terms of their relationship with
观点。是的。一直以来，这对伯利和沃尔辛厄姆来说都是一个巨大的、难以估量的问题。玛丽活着显然对伊丽莎白构成了巨大的威胁。她是天主教徒，又是伊丽莎白最明显的继承人，这一事实不断激励着天主教异见分子试图暗杀伊丽莎白或以其他方式将她赶下王位。但伊丽莎白不会容忍将她除掉，而且这样做的法律机制也不存在。但思罗克莫顿阴谋对伯利和沃尔辛厄姆的影响是巨大的，因为他们现在绝对决心要除掉苏格兰女王玛丽，无论付出什么代价。无论法律代价如何，无论外交代价如何，无论在他们与
their royal mistress Elizabeth Tudor. The immediate priority for them is massively to tighten the security around Mary to ensure that she can't get letters out. And so to this end, she's placed under much stricter confinement. She's given a much stricter and sterner governor. Her correspondence networks are systematically throttled. And the result of this is that she no longer has access to the outside world. But that's not enough, because Burley and Walsingham, they, really need to find a way to bring Mary to trial, to sentence, to execution. And it is with these goals in mind that in the wake of Throckmorton's execution, Burley and Walsingham draw up a really remarkable document. And this is what comes to be called the bond of association. And it begins
他们的皇家女主人伊丽莎白·都铎的关系方面付出什么代价。他们的当务之急是极大地加强对玛丽的安保，以确保她无法将信件送出。因此，她被置于更严格的监禁之下。她被安排了一位更严格、更严厉的监管人。她的通信网络被系统性地切断了。结果就是她不再能接触到外部世界。但这还不够，因为伯利和沃尔辛厄姆真的需要找到一种方法将玛丽送上审判台，判刑并处决。正是怀着这些目标，在思罗克莫顿被处决后，伯利和沃尔辛厄姆起草了一份非常了不起的文件。这就是所谓的“联合契约”，它始于
with a very simple but ingenious provision. And this provision is that anyone who is responsible for the death of Elizabeth will be ineligible to succeed her. and this will become law. Mary isn't mentioned by name, but she doesn't need to be mentioned by name. It's obviously targeted at her. And by the time this bond of association is signed off by the Privy Council at a meeting in Hampton Court on the 19th October 1584, a further crucial provision has been added. And this states that anyone who is responsible for the death of Elizabeth will be put to death
一个非常简单但巧妙的条款。这一条款规定，任何对伊丽莎白的死亡负有责任的人都将失去继承她的资格。这将成为法律。玛丽的名字没有被提及，但不需要提及她的名字。这显然是针对她的。当这份联合契约在1584年10月19日于汉普顿宫举行的枢密院会议上签署时，又增加了一个关键条款。该条款规定，任何对伊丽莎白的死亡负有责任的人都将被处死
whether they were aware of the assassination plot or not. So just to spell out what that means, if a Catholic assassin kills Elizabeth with the aim of putting Mary Queen of Scots on the English throne, Mary will be subject to death, even if she didn't know anything about the assassination plot. And is it just aimed at Mary, do you think, or is it aimed at other people as well?
无论他们是否知道暗杀阴谋。所以，解释一下这意味着什么，如果一名天主教刺客为了让苏格兰女王玛丽登上英国王位而杀死了伊丽莎白，玛丽将被处死，即使她对暗杀阴谋一无所知。你认为这只是针对玛丽，还是也针对其他人？
No, it's just aimed at Mary. Right. And the Privy Council, when they sign this office law, They know that, and they also know that effectively they are formally committing themselves to a kind of lynch law. And they then send it out into the streets of London and the kingdom beyond, and thousands and thousands of loyal Englishmen and women add their signatures to this bond of association. And if they're illiterate, then they sign it with their cross. And amazingly, on the 5th of January 1585, Mary Queen of Scots herself puts her name to this bond. See, I think that's smart politics from her.
不，这只是针对玛丽。没错。当枢密院签署这份法律时，他们知道这一点，他们也知道他们实际上是在正式承诺一种私刑。然后他们把它发送到伦敦街头和王国各地，成千上万忠诚的英国男女在这一联合契约上签了名。如果他们不识字，他们就画十字签名。令人惊讶的是，1585年1月5日，苏格兰女王玛丽本人也在这份契约上签了名。你看，我认为这是她聪明的政治手段。
Yeah, it is, isn't it? Because she can feel the noose is tightening around her neck. And so she wants to do all that she can to loosen it. Yeah. But the question is, you know, will she succeed? And what remains her preeminent ambition, namely to replace Elizabeth on the throne of England? Can she really be trusted to give up on that? And what do all of these developments, you know, the expulsions, you know, the expulsions,
是的，确实如此，不是吗？因为她能感觉到绞索正在收紧。所以她想尽一切办法来放松它。是的。但问题是，你知道，她会成功吗？她最崇高的野心，即取代伊丽莎白登上英国王位，还能实现吗？她真的值得信任去放弃那个野心吗？所有这些事态发展，你知道，驱逐，你知道，驱逐
of Mendoza, the issue of this kind of lynch law, what does this mean for England's relations with Spain? So the diplomatic relations have been broken. The flames of Protestant revolt are blazing in the low countries. There is no end to that conflict in sight. On top of that, top sea dog, Sir Francis Drake, he is very much on the scene and he has been pressing Elizabeth and the Privy Council to let him have another crack at the Spanish. So I think it is no exaggeration to say that the drum beat of war is sounding. Wow. Drake's drum is sounding and the Tudor Cold War is hotting up. Very, very exciting. And next week it will be red hot. It'll be white hot, in fact. Scorching hot.
门多萨，这种私刑法律的发布，这对英国与西班牙的关系意味着什么？外交关系已经破裂。新教起义的火焰在低地国家燃烧。那场冲突看不到尽头。最重要的是，顶级海狗弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士，他非常活跃，一直在向伊丽莎白和枢密院施压，要求让他再次打击西班牙人。所以我认为毫不夸张地说，战争的鼓声正在响起。哇。德雷克的鼓声正在响起，都铎王朝的冷战正在升温。非常非常令人兴奋。下周它会变得火热。事实上，会变得白热化。灼热。
Incredibly hot. All sorts of drama to come because we are, of course, approaching one of the most dramatic moments in English history. So imagine that you wanted to hear those episodes straight away. Next week's episodes. If there any way you could do that, well, The good news is there is, you could be a member of the Restis History Club. You could be a member of our own Thront Morton plot. And if you're not already a conspirator, the way to join the sinister enterprise is to head to the restishistory.com. That's the only way by, people don't know this, Tom, but this is the only way that
极其火热。各种戏剧性的事情即将发生，因为我们当然正在接近英国历史上最戏剧性的时刻之一。所以想象一下，如果你想直接听到那些剧集。下周的剧集。如果你有什么办法能做到这一点，好吧，好消息是有的，你可以成为“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员。你可以成为我们自己思罗克莫顿阴谋的一员。如果你还不是一个阴谋者，加入这个邪恶事业的方法就是前往therestisistory.com。这是唯一的方法，人们不知道这一点，汤姆，但这确实是唯一的方法
you can get all the amazing benefits, genuinely incredible benefits. We've never mentioned that before, have we? Never. And it's important to point that out for the first time. Dominic, I have even more exciting news. because we are running a summer sale. And so for a limited time, if you want to sign up to the rest of history club, listen about the dinosaurs and a host of other supplementary benefits,
你可以获得所有惊人的福利，真正令人难以置信的福利。我们以前从未提到过，对吧？从来没有。第一次指出这一点很重要。多米尼克，我还有更令人兴奋的消息。因为我们正在进行夏季促销。所以，在有限的时间内，如果你想注册“历史其余部分俱乐部”，听听关于恐龙和许多其他补充福利的内容，
then you will get an extra 20% off an annual membership using the code summer 26. And this is only valid until the 31st of August. So hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry, while stocks last. Anyway, listen, do all those things. Listen to the series. Join the club. It'd be brilliant. And we'll see you next time for.
那么你将使用代码summer 26获得年度会员额外20%的折扣。这仅在8月31日前有效。所以快点，快点，快点，快点，售完即止。总之，听着，做所有这些事情。听这个系列。加入俱乐部。那会很棒。我们下次再见，为了
the road to the Spanish Armada. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Ready to take your investing knowledge to pro-level. This is Fidelity Connects, your daily edge in the markets. Get deep insights on real-time market topics that may impact your investment portfolio. Listen to Fidelity Connects on Spotify today and power your next move tomorrow. Hey guys, this is Anthony Scaramucci for the rest of politics, US. Caddy Kay and I want to tell you about our North American tour in October. Donald Trump is re-reli- the history of the United States. From trade wars to immigration crackdowns to global conflicts,
通往西班牙无敌舰队之路。再见。再见。准备好将你的投资知识提升到专业水平了吗？这是Fidelity Connects，你在市场上的每日优势。获取可能影响你投资组合的实时市场主题的深度见解。今天就在Spotify上收听Fidelity Connects，为你的下一个举措提供动力。嘿，伙计们，我是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，为了“政治其余部分，美国”。凯蒂和我，我想告诉你们我们10月份的北美巡演。唐纳德·特朗普正在重写美国历史。从贸易战到移民打击，再到全球冲突，
we are here to make sense of all of it. You know, we're in an era defined by depolarization, and American institutions are breaking under Donald Trump. Katty and I will be live on stage, breaking down what's really happening, sharing insider perspectives, and answering your questions. This October, we're heading to Toronto, Boston, New York,
我们在这里是为了理清这一切。你知道，我们处于一个由去极化定义的时代，美国机构在唐纳德·特朗普的领导下正在崩溃。凯蒂和我将现场直播，剖析真正发生的事情，分享内部观点，并回答你们的问题。今年10月，我们将前往多伦多、波士顿、纽约、
Washington, D.C., a host of other American cities to get into all of the political action. We would love to see you there. Come and join us. So head to the rest is politics, US.com, to get your tickets and come see us live. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
华盛顿特区以及其他许多美国城市，参与所有的政治行动。我们很乐意在那里见到你们。快来加入我们。所以前往therestispoliticsus.com获取门票，来看我们的现场直播。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。